programming throwdown episode 75 arduino take it away patrick welcome back to a non-interview programming throwdown. That's right. I really like the interview episodes. I always like talking to people. Well, I just like talking. I like talking to people. But, you know, sometimes I was sitting down and, you know, picking my book of the show and my program show.
Programming Throwdown 第75期：Arduino。帕特里克，交给你了。欢迎回到非访谈类的 Programming Throwdown。没错，我真的很喜欢访谈节目，我一直很喜欢和人交流。好吧，我只是喜欢说话，我喜欢和人交流。但是，你知道，有时候我坐下来，挑选我的节目推荐书籍和节目内容时。
I'm like, I kind of miss doing this. Like, I've been too long without being able to talk about something I've read. So, actually, I like a lot. I had a lot of books and I had to I actually did too yeah I mean I um I don't know if I mentioned this in the past episode but um audible uh you know I uh uh they reach out to me in like Christmas and I don't know if you got the same thing I did but they said you could pre-pay for the year and it was significantly cheaper. Yeah, almost like half price or something. Yeah, that's right.
我就觉得，我有点怀念做这个了。我已经太久没能谈论我读过的东西了。所以，实际上，我真的很喜欢。我有很多书，我不得不……我确实也做了，是的，我的意思是，我不知道我是否在过去的节目中提到过这一点，但是 Audible，你知道，他们在大约圣诞节的时候联系了我，我不知道你是否也收到了同样的消息，但他们说你可以预付一年的费用，而且会便宜很多。是的，几乎是半价之类的。是的，没错。
It was half price and I got all 12 credits up front. And yeah, I jumped on that. And yeah, and so I've been reading a ton of books. I picked one of them for Book of the Show. But yeah, we definitely have a backlog. Yes, I also did. Oh no, I did it a while before that so i've actually had the 12 credits for a while but then you still get the access this is anyways
确实是半价，我预先获得了全部 12 个积分。是的，我抓住了这个机会。所以，我一直在读大量的书。我选了其中一本作为节目推荐书籍。但是，是的，我们确实积压了很多书。是的，我也一样。哦不，我在那之前很久就这么做了，所以我实际上已经拥有这 12 个积分有一段时间了，但你仍然可以获得访问权限，总之。
this is off topic and you get the access to the sales for the thing and i my commute is just long enough that like i i just really enjoy listening to the books and i really make to make it through them quite quickly um and so i have sort of a large catalog. But the 12 credits, like one per month, isn't really sufficient. So then they have sales where they run stuff for, you know, $2 or $5 or buy one, get one free. Oh, nice. Or something. And so they'll email you like, oh, there's a sale going on.
这跑题了，你可以获得那些促销活动的访问权限，而且我的通勤时间刚好够长，所以我真的很喜欢听书，而且我确实能很快地听完它们。所以，我有一个相当大的书库。但是 12 个积分，也就是每月一个，确实不够。所以他们会有促销活动，比如 2 美元或 5 美元，或者买一送一之类的。哦，不错。或者类似的东西。所以他们会给你发邮件，说，哦，现在有促销活动。
And I end up almost always picking up like a book or two from the sales just to supplement the fact of uh you know having enough to listen to nice very so all right but the first topic i want to talk about is something that i've actually talked with people about work about when we interview people at work this is a discussion that comes out and so i thought it'd be interesting to to sort of discuss it here what you have to say i have some thoughts on it i guess um and then generally you know there won't be an authoritative answer here but at least if people in the audience have this question though i've heard it and that is should programmers be expected to code in their free time uh and i slightly changed it to working programmers because i think a lot of people listening
我几乎总是会从促销活动中买一两本书，只是为了补充一下，你知道，有足够的东西可以听。很好，非常……好吧，但我想谈的第一个话题是我在工作中面试别人时确实和人讨论过的事情，这是一个经常出现的话题，所以我认为在这里讨论一下会很有趣。你想说什么？我想我有一些想法，而且通常情况下，你知道，这里不会有一个权威的答案，但至少如果听众中有这个问题的话，虽然我听说过，那就是：程序员是否应该被期望在业余时间写代码？我稍微把它改成了“在职程序员”，因为我认为很多听众。
uh who are students are not paid to program or doing a different job and doing programming on the side only do programming in their free time. But if your job is a software engineer or that you're being paid to do programming, is it an expectation that you should have a project on the side or something where you regularly do code outside of work to show your passion for programming? So I'll let you go first, Jason. So I teed it up for you, and let's see where you regularly do code outside of work to show your passion for programming. So I'll let you go first, Jason. So I teed it up for you, and let's see where you drive the boat.
那些是学生的人，他们没有因为编程而获得报酬，或者从事着不同的工作，只是在业余时间进行编程。但是，如果你的工作是软件工程师，或者你因为编程而获得报酬，那么是否有一种期望，即你应该有一个副业项目，或者经常在工作之外写代码，以展示你对编程的热情？所以我让你先来，杰森。所以我为你铺好了路，让我们看看你是否经常在工作之外写代码来展示你对编程的热情。所以我让你先来，杰森。所以我为你铺好了路，让我们看看你如何掌控局面。
All right. It's a tough question. So, okay, here's what I'll say just as a preface to this. I think that, you know, your job is kind of a gradient, right? So, in other words, you kind of get what you put in in and hopefully, you know, obviously it's not an absolute, but in general, you get what you put in. And there isn't really like this binary, you know, like, OK, you cross the threshold type thing. So, I mean, I would say, you know, if people are doing some work on the side, That's part of kind of building your brand. And so I feel like it's going to help you in the same way as there's tons of things
好的。这是一个棘手的问题。那么，好吧，作为开场白，我想说的是：我认为你的工作是一种渐进的过程，对吧？换句话说，你投入了多少，就会得到多少。当然，这并不是绝对的，但总的来说，你投入多少就会得到多少。并没有那种二元对立，你知道，比如，好吧，你跨过了这个门槛之类的。所以，我的意思是，如果人们在做一些副业，那是建立个人品牌的一部分。所以我感觉这会像其他很多事情一样对你有帮助。
that could help you. If you do, I don't know, speech coaching, it could help you, you know. But when you say the word expected, anytime you use words like expected, it's kind of, it's breaking down like that view I have of work where it's sort of this bank account and you contribute more or less and you get returns. And it's turning it into more like, you know, what's the bare minimum I have to do? You know, like there's basically two paths in life and how do I make sure I'm on the right path? And so, you know, I have kind of an issue with,
比如，如果你做演讲培训，它可能会对你有帮助。但是当你使用“期望”这个词时，任何时候你使用像“期望”这样的词，它都在破坏我对工作的看法，即工作就像一个银行账户，你贡献多或少，就会得到回报。它正在把它变成更像“我必须做的最低限度是什么？”你知道，生活中基本上有两条路，我该如何确保我走在正确的道路上？所以，你知道，我对这个问题的前提有点意见。
I guess, the whole premise of the question. So I would say, you know, no, I mean, you shouldn't really be expected to do anything. But it's also, I think it would help almost anybody. And so, you know, I guess the question is, do you want to get more out of your career? And then the second question is, you know, based on what you're doing now, is this the best, you know, bang for your buck? In terms of like, you know, from what you're not already doing to better your career, is this the next best thing? And I would say actually, yeah, I mean, the thing about this that's nice is typically it's some project that's not, I mean, certainly it's not related to your work. That's why you're allowed to do it in your free time. You get full credit for it.
我想说，不，我的意思是，你不应该真的被期望去做任何事情。但同时，我认为这对几乎任何人都有帮助。所以，我想问题是，你是否想从你的职业生涯中获得更多？第二个问题是，基于你现在所做的，这是性价比最高的吗？就你为了改善职业生涯而尚未做的事情而言，这是下一个最好的事情吗？我会说，实际上，是的。关于这一点的好处是，通常它是一些项目，我的意思是，当然它与你的工作无关。这就是为什么你可以在业余时间做它。你可以获得全部功劳。
You know, it's much more resume building than the code at work, which you generally can't share. So yeah, I mean, I don't think anyone should be expected to do this, but I would say this would probably be on my top 10 list of things to do to, you know, make your career go further. That's my two cents. So before I i say my piece i'll say it a different way would you with not knowing anything else about a person's resume or let's say we have we did a you know a study where we gave you two resumes that happened to be identical except one of them had work that they did on the side uh you know in their free time or pointed to a github repo where they had some
你知道，这比在工作中写的代码更能建立简历，因为工作中的代码通常不能分享。所以，是的，我的意思是，我不认为任何人应该被期望这样做，但我会说这可能是我职业生涯发展建议的前十名。这就是我的拙见。所以在发表我的看法之前，我会换一种方式说：如果对一个人的简历一无所知，或者假设我们做了一项研究，我们给你两份完全相同的简历，除了其中一份有他们在业余时间所做的工作，或者指向了一个 GitHub 仓库，里面有一些。
projects that they worked on actively, not not like in the past, but they're actively working on projects, like how much more weight would you give that over the person who didn't have something all else being equal? Yeah, I mean, probably a lot, personally. I mean, again, I mean, if that if, if, if all else is equal, yeah, I mean, if that if if if all else is equal. Yeah. I mean, I would consider somebody who. So so there's two parts of it. One part is if if the person has these side projects and they're actually popular, that there's a variety of skills that that make that happen. Right. I mean, if someone just took tutorials off the internet
他们积极参与的项目，不是过去的项目，而是他们正在积极参与的项目，相比于没有这些项目的人，你会给前者多少权重？是的，我的意思是，个人而言，可能会给很多。我的意思是，同样，如果一切条件相同，是的，如果一切条件相同。我的意思是，我会考虑那些……所以这里有两部分。一部分是，如果这个人有这些副业项目，而且它们实际上很受欢迎，那么这就需要多种技能来实现。对吧？我的意思是，如果有人只是从网上拿了教程。
and implemented them, and all of their projects have zero stars, and it was just like an academic exercise, that's kind of different. But if someone has some projects that they built and they actually have a following, yeah, I mean, I would say that's pretty significant, yeah. Okay, so I think this is a difference because actually you and I differ on this.
并实现了它们，而他们所有的项目都没有星标，这只是像学术练习一样，那就不一样了。但如果有人构建了一些项目，并且它们确实有追随者，是的，我的意思是，我会说这相当重要，是的。好吧，所以我认为这是一个分歧，因为实际上你和我在这一点上不同。
So you do do programming outside of work and I almost do no programming outside of work. And so I'll bias the other way, which is I actually, you are right, of course, with almost everything you're safe in saying it depends. Yeah, of course. So if you have, you know, a popular like, wow, this is a true almost equal to a job level of project that you maintain. Right. Where I might interview you, even if you weren't a programmer, even if you weren't working at category almost um but if you're just a person who has even a mildly popular or not at all popular mildly popular i guess is ambiguous if you have something that i hadn't heard of uh or that a quick google search doesn't reveal to me is like a very commonly used piece of software like how many stars like maybe your project has you know less than 100 stars or something yeah Then I basically don't count that at all. It's not even interesting to me.
所以你在工作之外确实进行编程，而我几乎不在工作之外进行编程。所以我会有相反的偏见，也就是，你是对的，当然，你说“视情况而定”几乎总是安全的。是的，当然。所以如果你有一个像……哇，这是一个真正几乎等同于工作级别的项目，并且你在维护它。对吧？我可能会面试你，即使你不是程序员，即使你不在那个类别工作。但如果你只是一个拥有哪怕是稍微受欢迎，或者根本不受欢迎的项目的人——“稍微受欢迎”我想是有歧义的——如果你有一些我没听说过的东西，或者快速的谷歌搜索没有向我揭示它是一个非常常用的软件，比如你的项目有多少星标，比如可能不到 100 个星标之类的，是的，那么我基本上根本不计算它。这对我来说甚至不感兴趣。
In fact, when people put their... And this is going to differ, which is why it's good that we're both presenting our opinions. Sure. But I almost never go to people's GitHub pages on their resumes. I'm just not interested. Oh, yes. I'm totally the opposite. But I think to your point point if it doesn't have
事实上，当人们把他们的……这会有所不同，这就是为什么我们两人都提出各自的观点是好的。当然。但我几乎从不去看人们简历上的 GitHub 页面。我只是不感兴趣。哦，是的。我完全相反。但我认为，说到你的观点，如果它没有。
a fall like i don't know i mean i don't want to put a star number on it because it's much more like abstract than that people are going to be buying stars yeah but if it if it doesn't have like if there's never been a pull request you're the only committer it has three stars then it's it's the same as nothing um but no i mean i look and if it has some pull requests and there's some discussion and the person is making some decisions, um, but I can, I can suss out that.
追随者……我不知道，我的意思是，我不想给它设定一个星标数字，因为它比那更抽象。人们会去买星标。是的，但如果它没有……如果从来没有过拉取请求（pull request），你是唯一的提交者，它只有三个星标，那么它就和什么都没有一样。但是，不，我的意思是，我会看，如果它有一些拉取请求，并且有一些讨论，而且这个人正在做出一些决定，那么我可以……我可以察觉到这一点。
Oops, sorry. Good. Oh no. I was gonna say, especially if there's, if it's big enough where you have sort of conflicting interests type thing, or you have to do some type of organizational work.
抱歉。好的。哦不。我想说的是，特别是如果它足够大，你有某种相互冲突的利益，或者你必须做某种组织工作。
Um, and again, this is all things being equal. Here's one thing I will say just to finish my part is, is if I don't have that information, so let's say there's somebody who does, does nothing outside of work. Well, then I would spend more time in the interview. You know, I wouldn't really talk about their non-existent GitHub, but I would be spending that time talking to them about work situations and, and,
嗯，同样，这是在一切条件相同的情况下。我要说的最后一件事是，如果我没有这些信息，假设有人在工作之外什么都不做。那么我会在面试中花更多时间。你知道，我不会真的谈论他们不存在的 GitHub，但我会花时间与他们谈论工作情况，并且。
uh, you know, presumably they would, they would, uh, they would be able to fill in there. Yeah. That's what I was going to say is,
你知道，大概他们能够填补那里的空白。是的，我正要说的是。
is basically that, which is I'm going to ask about that anyways, to understand how does this person deal with conflicting interests? How do they manage their time? What are the kinds of things they like to do? So I'm going to ask those anyways. And as far as like the expectation, I mean, I think there is a belief, at least some blogs and whatever will say that, you know, oh, basically you it's an expectation. If you're not passionate enough about programming to do it with like all your spare time, then like that's not the kind of person they're interested in hiring.
基本上就是这样，也就是我无论如何都会问这个问题，以了解这个人如何处理相互冲突的利益？他们如何管理时间？他们喜欢做什么样的事情？所以我无论如何都会问这些问题。至于“期望”，我的意思是，我认为有一种信念，至少一些博客之类的会说，你知道，哦，基本上这是一个期望。如果你对编程的热情不足以让你用所有的业余时间去做，那么这就不是他们有兴趣雇佣的那种人。
And those people do exist. I mean, I'm not going to counter it, but I personally don't. I don't think that's not the kind of person they're interested in hiring. And those people do exist. I mean, I'm not going to counter it. But I personally don't think that's true at all. I don't hold it as a – it is definitely not a negative at all for me if you don't have any external to your work projects. But that isn't to say – and I think Jason alluded to this in the beginning, although he might have said it slightly stronger than I did, which is if you do have something, it can be a benefit. Um, if for nothing else than for teaching you
而这样的人确实存在。我的意思是，我不会反驳它，但我个人不认为……那不是他们有兴趣雇佣的那种人。而这样的人确实存在。我的意思是，我不会反驳它。但我个人根本不认为这是真的。我一点也不认为如果你没有工作之外的项目是一个负面因素。但这并不是说——我认为杰森在开始时提到了这一点，尽管他说的可能比我稍微强烈一点——如果你确实有一些东西，它可以是一个好处。嗯，如果仅仅是为了教你。
what it is, you're not getting from work. And I think this is the difference is if you are currently, you know, and I'm just, and I'm not saying good or bad, I'm just going to pick something like if you're currently doing, you know, website, JavaScript, front end stuff, and you want to get into distributed data processing. But at work, you're literally just slammed with, you know, layout of, you know, the website, and you're not getting the education you need, it's going to be very difficult oftentimes to convince a team or a company to hire you for work in something you haven't proven yourself in doing external projects even if they aren't popular even if they don't go read your github will teach you the expertise you need to be able to talk confidently at least at
你从工作中得不到的东西。我认为这就是区别：如果你目前，你知道，我不是说好坏，我只是随便举个例子，如果你目前正在做网站、JavaScript、前端的东西，而你想进入分布式数据处理。但在工作中，你简直被网站布局之类的东西淹没了，你没有得到你需要的教育，通常很难说服一个团队或公司雇佣你去做你没有证明过的事情。外部项目，即使它们不受欢迎，即使他们不去读你的 GitHub，也会教给你在面试中至少在某种程度上自信地谈论所需的专业知识。
some level in an interview now you should still be honest that hey i've never you know i only done this in my spare time or only you know examples, examples. I've never done this at my company. Like you should never be deceitful there, but you can still express a confidence that you understand what it is to do, you know, distributed data processing or whatever. And I think in those ways, it is sometimes necessary as part of resume building or part of learning to do extracurricular programming yeah i guess the question is like i mean if we were to come up with a list of you know someone comes to you and they say i want to uh you know improve my career you know i'm software engineer i want to be software engineer level n plus one or something like that like how would you prioritize you know
现在，你仍然应该诚实地说，嘿，我从来没有……你知道，我只在业余时间做过这个，或者只做过例子。我从来没有在我的公司做过这个。你永远不应该在那里欺骗，但你仍然可以表达一种自信，即你了解如何做分布式数据处理之类的东西。我认为在这些方面，作为简历建设或学习的一部分，进行课外编程有时是必要的。是的，我想问题是，如果我们要列出一个清单，有人来找你说，我想提高我的职业生涯，我是软件工程师，我想成为 N+1 级别的软件工程师之类的，你会如何优先考虑在业余时间写代码与其他事情相比？你会给出的建议是什么，会比这更好吗？我的意思是，是的，这很困难，因为我认为有些事情你可以做，例如，我不认为它必须是……我认为它可以是阅读，比如阅读关于其他人如何做事情，阅读……听起来很傻，但你知道，这很有意义，Reddit 编程或 Hacker News，你知道，阅读书籍，比如《代码大全》之类的，或者关于如何协商晋升之类的东西。或者甚至，不一定非要有一个函数式编程项目，只是试着读完一本函数式编程书。我认为这些事情也能有所帮助。
coding in your spare time versus other things like like you know what would be sort of your advice uh that would be better than this right i mean yeah it's difficult because i mean i think there are things you can do for instance i don't think it has to be I think it could be reading like reading about how you know other people do stuff reading you know it sounds like goofy but you know that makes sense reddit programming or hacker news um you know reading books like you know uh coding complete or whatever you know something about how to negotiate a promotion sure something like that. Or even, you know, not necessarily having a project in functional programming, but just trying to make it through a functional programming book. I think those kinds of things can also help.
它不一定非要是实际的编程、调试和构建一个项目到完成。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，我们可以达成共识的一点是，如果有人 GitHub 是空的，并且他们说他们在工作之外不做任何编程，那并不是一个取消资格的因素。我的意思是，也许……只是其中一件事，有些工作是……我不想把这个搞砸，但我见过一些工作，有人给你一张他们在 Photoshop 中画的应用程序图片，他们只是说，看，我想要应用程序看起来像这样。对于那种工作，他们真的很看重吞吐量。对吧。所以如果你得到一份工作，吞吐量是最重要的事情，比如每小时的工作代码行数之类的。
It doesn't have to be actual programming and debugging and building a project to completion. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, one thing we can both agree on is that if someone doesn't, if someone has an empty GitHub and they say they do no programming outside of work, that's not a disqualifier. I mean, that's, I maybe just so one of the things there are jobs where, and I don't do to kind of mess this up, but I've seen jobs where somebody hands you a picture of an app like that they drew in Photoshop and they just say, look, I want the app to look like this. And and for those kind of jobs, they're really interested in kind of throughput. Right. And so if you're getting a job where like throughput is the most important thing like lines of code per hour worked or something like that
那么也许有人会说，哦，你知道，我在支付每个人的工资，这个在业余时间做所有这些事情的人，也许我可以让他们每周工作 100 小时，因为他们有更多的精力。但那些不是你想要的工作。对吧。所以，换句话说，那些期望程序员在业余时间工作的公司，可能不是你想要的工作。所以，如果你是一名开发人员，我不会对自己提出这种要求。好吧，那是我要说的，但对我来说，我尝试去面试、换团队、在公司内部调动，无论什么必要，我都尝试。
then maybe someone could say oh you know i'm paying everyone's salary this person who does all this stuff on the side maybe i could get them to do a hundred hours of work a week because you know they have more energy, but those are not the jobs you want. Right. So, so in other words, the jobs where they would expect their programmers to work in their free time are probably not the jobs that, that you want. So, so I wouldn't, I wouldn't put this demand on yourself if you're a developer. Well, that was, that was something i was going to say though for me i try to get jobs interview change teams move within a company whatever is necessary to try
去得到一份工作，在那里我能得到……听起来很糟糕，但得到我在工作中对编程所需的满足感。所以，是的，如果我对嵌入式编程真的很感兴趣，那么我会加入一个试图做底层编程的团队，或者……我有多在乎那个，因为我想在工作中做我真正热爱的事情，并从中获得那种满足感。然后当我回家时，我不需要，我不觉得“哦，我没有做我感兴趣的工作”。是的，我的意思是，那是我们不同的另一个问题。如果我有那种心态，我每三个月就会辞职。我会换工作。但这只是因为我们在这方面的天性不同。但是，是的，我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题。
to get a job where i get sounds bad but get like the fulfillment i need about programming at work so yeah if i'm like hey if i'm really interested in embedded programming then like i'm going to join a team that's trying to do low level programming or way like how much i care about that because i want to be doing the thing at work that i'm really passionate about and that sort of get that fulfillment and then when i get home i don't need to i don't feel like oh i'm not doing the kind of work i'm interested in yeah i mean that's that's another issue where we differ like if i had that mentality, I would be quitting every three months. I would be changing jobs. But that just comes down to we have different natures around that. But yeah, I think it's a really interesting question.
我认为很难有一个好的答案。我要说的一件事是，如果你不在业余时间写代码，绝对不要给自己施加压力。我不认为这应该是什么强制性的要求。而且，值得一提的是，我确实试图说服那些有这种态度的人，即应该有课外工作，我确实试图说服他们，这不一定是真的。因为，我的意思是，也有非常个人的原因，为什么现在可能不是你做这些事情的好时机。你知道，如果你刚刚……而且你并不是把它当作借口，但也许你最近在生活中经济拮据，不得不做第二份非技术工作，或者你有了孩子，或者你的家庭中有疾病需要照顾。
And I think it's very hard to have a good answer. The one thing I would say is definitely don't put pressure on yourself if you don't don't code in your free time i don't think that this is should be some kind of mandate or something and and for what it's worth i do try to convince people who have this attitude that like there should be extracurricular work i do try to convince them that this is not necessarily true because i mean there's also very personal reasons why it just might not be a good time for you to be doing things right you know if you just and and it's not always you're not bringing up as an excuse but maybe you in your life recently struggled financially and had to work a second non-technical job or you know you you're uh had a child or you had a illness in your family you need to take care
也许你自己生病了，所有这些都可能是某个人一两年或三年没有做这类事情的原因。是的。而在另一方面，可能有人在业余时间做了很多事情，因为他们在工作中表现不佳。所以你是在奖励一种糟糕的情况。对吧。所以，是的，我认为无论什么事情，都有很多因素决定你是在招聘，还是在试图改善自己的职业生涯，而这只是其中之一。但是，是的，任何时候你看到这种“期望”，那可能是一个危险信号。你知道，好吧，进入新闻和链接。我的第一个是关于使用 Lua 的游戏编程教程。我要说的是 Love，但如果错了，我很抱歉。
of maybe you yourself were ill um all of these things could be reasons why the person for a year or two or three years hasn't done this kind of stuff. Yeah. And on the flip side, there could be someone who's done a lot of stuff in the free time because they are just not doing well in their job. And so you're kind of rewarding a bad situation there. Right. So yeah, I think with anything, there's there's a lot of ingredients that go into whether you're hiring whether you're trying to improve your own career and this is like this is one of them but yeah anytime you see this like expectation that's probably a red flag you know well on to news and links my first one is uh a game programming tutorial using Lua. And I'm going to say it, Love, but if that's wrong, I'm sorry.
不，是 Love。你是对的。好的。我以前确实用过这个。这是一个相当不错的库。哦，好的。所以 Lua 是一种脚本语言，而 Love 是一个用 Lua 制作 2D 游戏的框架。关于这个有几件有趣的事情，所以链接。
No, it's Love. You're right. Okay. I've actually used this before. It's a pretty good library. Oh, okay. So Lua is a scripting language, and Love is a framework for making 2D games in Lua. And there's a couple of interesting things about this so the the links
在节目说明中，但正在制作的游戏叫 Bite Path，它之所以有趣，是因为教程是在一系列 GitHub Issues 中进行的。所以那个人制作了 GitHub Issues，描述了教程的所有部分。它之所以有趣，还因为 Lua 一直是那种……哦，我甚至不知道多少年来一直在我的“我真的应该熟悉并使用它”的清单上。
in the show notes but the game being made is called bite path um and it's a it's it's probably interesting because the tutorial takes place in a series of github issues so the person made github issues that describe all of the parts of the tutorial it's also interesting because lua has been one of those things that like oh i don't even know for how many years has been on my like list of i should really get you know get acquainted with this and working with it um and i've always wanted to do some sort of like simple or retro style 2d game in my like giant list of things i never get to uh same here one day i'll you know retire but i'll actually just be super busy in retirement because i have to get through all this stuff i never did um and this is like one of those anyways it really struck a
我一直想在我那堆永远做不完的事情清单中做某种简单的或复古风格的 2D 游戏。我也是，有一天我会退休，但我退休后会超级忙，因为我必须完成所有我从未做过的事情。这就像其中之一。总之，它真的触动了我的心弦。就像，哦，我想去这样做。只是谈论我们在业余时间编程，而我根本不做任何编程的事实意味着我遗憾地没有跟随这个教程。
bone for me it's like oh i i want to go do this and just talking about programming in our spare time and the fact that i don't do any of it means i didn't unfortunately follow this tutorial um But if you didn't see it when it was like kind of making the rounds, check it out. So you've used Love before? Just I ran some demos. I made a very simple thing with it and it looked pretty cool. Yeah. Have you done much with Lua before? I have a long time ago.
但是如果你在它流行的时候没有看到它，去看看吧。所以你以前用过 Love？我只是运行了一些演示。我用它做了一个非常简单的东西，看起来很酷。是的。你以前用过 Lua 做很多事情吗？我很久以前用过。
I actually wrote part of this thing called Diluculum, which you can look it up. I don't know if it even exists anymore. But it was basically a Lua C++ binding API. And you could access C++ objects in Lua and vice versa. And it's kind of like the Python API, like the boost Python type thing, but for Lua. Okay. So I was really into Lua.
我实际上写过一个叫 Diluculum 的东西的一部分，你可以查一下。我不知道它是否还存在。但它基本上是一个 Lua C++ 绑定 API。你可以在 Lua 中访问 C++ 对象，反之亦然。它有点像 Python API，像 Boost Python 那种东西，但针对 Lua。好的。所以我真的很喜欢 Lua。
This was, gosh, a long time ago. This was over 10 years ago. But yeah, honestly, as soon as I really found out about Python, like I'd heard about Python, but as soon as I really got into Python, which was, yeah, as I said, about 10 years ago, Lua just died
这，天哪，是很久以前的事了。这已经是 10 多年前的事了。但说实话，一旦我真正发现了 Python，就像我听说过 Python，但一旦我真正进入 Python，也就是，正如我所说，大约 10 年前，Lua 对我来说就立刻死了。
immediately for me. The Python C API is not as nice. It's harder to embed Python. But that kind of just slight mechanical challenge is not worth using any other scripting language
Python C API 没有那么好。嵌入 Python 更难。但那种轻微的机械挑战不值得使用任何其他脚本语言。
or interpreter language. So I've been pretty heavy into Python. But I did think Lua was good when I was using it. Nice. So my news is it's actually a YouTube channel that I've been following for a while, but I hadn't really talked about. It's pretty cool.
或解释器语言。所以我一直很深入地使用 Python。但我确实认为我在使用 Lua 时它很好。不错。所以我的新闻实际上是一个我关注了一段时间的 YouTube 频道，但我还没有真正谈论过。它很酷。
It's called Charisma on Command. It's very popular. A lot of people listening to the show have probably seen it before. They had one that was really cool. It was how to make any story interesting. And in the past, I've always kind of felt like, I don't know, I've always had sort of a, what's the word? Like I'm giving kind of side eyes to people who, who like over emotionalize things, you know, like when they're talking, they have too much inflection and things like that.
它叫 Charisma on Command。它非常受欢迎。很多听众可能以前见过它。他们有一个非常酷的视频，是关于如何让任何故事变得有趣。在过去，我一直觉得，我不知道，我一直有一种……怎么说呢？就像我给那些过度情绪化的人侧目，你知道，当他们说话时，他们有太多的语调变化之类的。
It's always kind of a big turnoff. Right. And I think it's still true. I mean, if you just overemphasize everything, people, you know, get kind of turned off, but, but this basically argues the opposite. It says, you know, part of it because you kind of know what you're going to say and you should watch a video, it goes into a variety to think before you talk in most settings. Most of us are doing that. And so you've already thought it through. You've already kind of played it out in your mind. And so now you're just reliving that, that, you know, you're just living out that prediction. And so just naturally when you talk, you're not, you're not using as much inflection as you want. And so it talks about that, a bunch of other things, but it really goes into detail on, you know, instead of just, because you see a lot of these things where it's like, you know,
这总是一种很大的反感。对吧。我认为这仍然是真的。我的意思是，如果你只是过度强调一切，人们会感到反感。但这个视频基本上论证了相反的观点。它说，你知道，部分原因是你知道你要说什么，你应该看一个视频，它会深入探讨在大多数场合说话前思考的各种方式。我们大多数人都在这样做。所以你已经想清楚了。你已经在脑海中演练过了。所以现在你只是在重温那个预测。所以当你说话时，你自然不会使用你想要的那么多语调变化。所以它谈到了这一点，还有很多其他事情，但它确实详细介绍了，你知道，而不是仅仅因为你看到很多这样的东西，比如“你可以说的三件有趣的事情”，而且全是关于内容和如何开启对话。他们通常看起来如此专注于内容。这只是，你知道，你无法控制内容。就像你要说 X。你如何让 X 变得有趣？我觉得这很酷。所以总的来说，这个 Charisma on Command 很棒。
three interesting things you can say, and it's all about the content and how to strike up a conversation. They usually look so focused on content. This is just, you know, you can't control the content. Like you're going to say X. How do you make X interesting? And I thought it was pretty cool. And so in general, this Charisma on Command is amazing.
我关注它有一段时间了。视频非常有用，非常有趣。但我认为这一个真的触动了我的心弦，因为它不仅有趣，而且也是我曾经反对的东西。然后当我看了视频后，它完全改变了我的想法。所以我还没有真正把它付诸实践。我不觉得我说话比平时更强调，但我感觉它让……你知道，它现在是合理的。就像这是我想做的事情。
I've been following it for a while. The videos are really useful, really interesting. But I thought this one really kind of struck a chord because it was not only interesting, but it was also something that one really kind of struck a chord because it was not only interesting, but it's also something that I was kind of against. And then when I watched the video, it completely changed my mind. So I haven't really taken it into practice. I don't feel like I'm speaking more emphatically than I usually do, but I feel like it makes, you know, it's plausible now. Like it's something I would want to do.
所以我一直在琢磨它，但我认为这是一个迷人的视频。我觉得我有点……我不知道，我从来没看过这个视频。我要去看看。这听起来很吸引人。
And so kind of mulling it over, but I thought it was a fascinating video. I feel like I kind of, I don't know, I've never seen this video. I'm going to go watch this. This sounds intriguing.
是的，你应该看看很多，如果你不关注这个人，一定要看看他的一些库。也许看看他最受欢迎的前五个视频之类的。但这真的非常非常有趣。有趣。
Yeah, you should check out a lot of, if you don't follow this guy, definitely go through some of his library. Maybe watch the top five most popular videos from him or something. But it's really, really interesting. Interesting.
我没想到人们会对那个有偏见。我想这说得通。好吧，是的。我的意思是，确实有那些人，你知道，当某人真的过度强调一切时。好吧，我想这有点……你知道，我总是想象当某人一开始就过度强调时。我脑子里就会假设这个人只是没有经历过艰难的生活。我的意思是，这不是正确的说法，但就像如果第一句话超级戏剧化，我只会假设它不会那么有趣。但是……但我猜有。
I didn't realize that people would have like a bias against that though. I guess that makes sense. Well, yeah. I mean, there are those people you kind of tell, you know, when somebody just really overemphasizes everything. Well, I guess it's kind of, you know, I always kind of picture when someone overemphasizes right off the bat. I kind of just in my head, I imagine that this person just hasn't been through a hard life. I mean, it's like not quite the right way to say it, but it's like if if if you know the first sentence is super dramatic i'm just going to assume that it's not going to be that interesting but is but i guess there's
好吧，我需要看视频，但我猜耸人听闻，或者只是过度修饰一切，或者深入其他细节并使某事变得激励人心或有趣之间是有区别的。是的，那也是真的。是的，他们谈论了这两者，因为听起来你所说的是，你不喜欢那些以“我度过了有史以来最糟糕的一天，我在一根头发上发现了一个分叉”开头的人，你只会觉得“哦，好吧”。所以要注意的是，显然当你说话很正常、完全没有排练时，你做的正好相反。所以通过增加一些强调，你真的在修复人类在即兴思考和说话方式上固有的问题。
okay i need to watch the video but i guess there's a difference between sensationalism or like just over embellishing everything or going into other details and making something motivating or you know interesting yeah that's true too yeah and they talk about they talk about kind of both of that because it sounds like what you're saying is like you don't like people who open with just this like i had the worst day ever i found a single split end on one of my hairs and you're just like oh okay yeah and so the thing to be aware of is apparently when when you talk kind of normally completely unrehearsed you're doing the opposite of that and so by adding some more emphasis you're really fixing just an inherent
所以，至少根据这个视频，你知道，你想过度强调一点，以抵消那种“自然倾向于强调不足”的倾向。但是等等，如果每个人都知道人们通常强调不足，那么他们已经在脑海中把它补回来了，所以如果你到处这样做，你真的只是在利用人们，就像“哇，那个人总是发生更有趣的事情”。是的，我的意思是，有一个关于总的来说，魅力和说服力是否具有剥削性的问题。我的意思是，也许吧，我不知道。但无论如何知道这一点是好的。这有点像……如果你知道如何掐住某人或类似的事情，对吧？我的意思是，知道这一点可能是有用的，也许极其罕见，但这并不意味着你必须到处去掐人。但是，拥有那种技能比没有它更有用，我想。好吧，也许你在说服我……不，好吧，是的，每个人现在都在看它，我真是个博学的人，这就是为什么我们的听众人数在下降。是的，完全正确，每秒都在下降。下一篇文章是“谁杀死了初级开发人员”。这是一篇由一位叫梅丽莎的女士在 Medium 上写的文章。
problem in the way human beings kind of think and speak on the fly and so um at least you know according to this video video um you know you want to overemphasize a little bit to cancel out the like natural tendency to underemphasize but wait but if everyone knows that people typically underemphasize then they've already beefed it back up in their heads so if you go around doing this you're really just like exploiting people like you're just like wow that person just has more interesting stuff happen to them all the time yeah i mean there's a question about in general like is charisma and persuasion like are these things exploitive um i mean maybe yeah i don't know but uh it's it's good to know either way it's sort of like uh um if you know let's say
她说，如果你看看人们的职位要求和外面的招聘信息，似乎很多人都在寻找高级工程师。我总是说，我也想要一只独角兽，因为人们要求，你知道，我想要一个有 10 年 Node.js 经验的人，就像，等等，Node.js 甚至还没出来 10 年，或者……也许有？不，我想没有。或者说一些类似的话，或者我想要一个有 5 年嵌入式编程经验、10 年 AI 经验和 6 年计算机视觉经验的人。这简直是不可能的，这个人必须……这根本不是一回事。
you know how to i don know, choke somebody or something, right? I mean, knowing that is probably useful, maybe extremely rarely, but it doesn't mean you have to go around choking everybody. Um, but, but having that skill is more useful than not having it, I suppose. Well, maybe you're persuading me to no okay yeah everyone's watching it right now that's just such a such a i'm such a savant that's why our listener count is dropping yeah exactly by the second the next article i have is who killed the junior developer uh this is a article written on medium by uh by a lady named melissa
嗯，但我认为它更深入地探讨了人们不想雇佣的问题。所以有那个方面，这并不完全是她所谈论的。但相反，她谈了很多关于公司如何想要他们所谓的“高级工程师”，关于什么是高级工程师有很多争论。但他们想要一个能立即上手、不需要指导或辅导的人。就像他们基本上知道如何完成工作。他们就像是计算机编程工作的工匠。以及她如何感觉到这一点，并且她在其中引入了一些关于女性与男性在工作场所如何处理指导角色或被指导角色的问题。我认为这很有趣。但这个。
and she is saying that you know that a lot of if you look at job requests that people have and you know postings out there and it seems a lot of people are looking for senior engineers and i always say i too would like a unicorn because people ask for you know i want someone with 10 years of experience in node.js and it's like wait node.js hasn't even been out 10 years or like right maybe it has no i guess it hasn't um and just say stuff like that or i would like someone with five years of experience and embedded programming and 10 years of ai experience and six years of computer vision experience. And it's like, no way, like this person would have to, like, there's just, that's not a thing.
事实是，公司想要雇佣高级工程师，因为他们不想花钱培训某人。他们想要一个能进来并立即开始工作的人。而且他们不仅不想培训某人，这不仅仅是他们必须等待初级开发人员变得像高级开发人员一样高效。他们通常还必须花费高级开发人员的时间来培养初级开发人员。而成为一名优秀的教师或导师的技能组合并不一定与你完成工作所需的技能组合相同。这不是一个革命性的发现，哦，这里有一个好的解决方案。但这只是指出了一些我观察到的事情。所以我在这里提出来，也就是我们经常看到这种情况，或者我经常看到这种情况发生，是的，让我们雇佣一个高级人员。我一直在我们的团队中推动。
Um, but I think it goes a little further into just people don't want to hire. So there's that aspect, which isn't exactly what, what, what she's talking about. But instead, um, she talks a lot about, you know, how companies want what they call sort of senior engineer, which there's a lot of debate about what senior engineer is. But they want someone who can hit the ground running, who doesn't have to be mentored or tutored. Like they basically know how to get their job done. They're like they are craftsmen at the job of computer programming. And how that, you know, she feels that and she brings into there some issues maybe with, you know, how women versus men in the workplace handle the mentoring role or the mentee role. And I think that's interesting. But this
让我们看看更多初级人员，因为有很多非常有才华的初级人员正在寻找机会。而且，面试过程的一部分是确保你为他们提供了合适的机会。但我还相信，带一名初级工程师并帮助他们在你的团队中成长为高级工程师，有助于他们变得非常高效，并在他们的角色中表现出色。而且，你知道，非常适合在文化、情况和团队中成长。如果你引入一个高级人员，在某些方面是好的，因为他们带来了很多经验，但他们带来了一定程度的惯性，几乎你想说行李，或者无论他们带来什么，他们带来了一个他们习惯的方向。
fact of, you know, companies want to hire senior engineers because they don't want to pay to train someone. They want to have someone who can come in and just start working right away. And not only do they not want to train someone, it's not just that they have to, you know, wait for the junior developer to get as efficient as a senior developer. But they also typically have to spend senior developer engineers times, you know, bringing up junior developers. And the skill set of being a really good teacher or mentor isn't necessarily the same skill set as exactly what you need to get your job done. And that's not a, you know, revelationary thing that, you know, oh, there's a good solution here. But just kind of pointing out something that I've observed. So I sort of bring it up here, which is we kind of see this, or I see this happen quite often where, yeah, let's hire a senior person. I've been pushing
他们习惯于朝着那个方向前进，他们认为事情应该这样做，有时这很好，但如果你的团队中有足够多这样的人，增加更多的声音往往会让我们慢下来一点，因为你会争论更多，重新挖掘为什么你的团队使用四个空格而不是两个空格进行缩进，或者不是制表符，对吧？因为这个人会带来……也许理所当然地，作为一名高级工程师，他们进来并开始质疑事情，但这并不总是你想要的。是的，我认为这篇文章超级有趣，我喜欢那个观点，你知道，按每小时的基础来看，就像我们过去谈论的那样，但你有某些时候，你知道，按每小时的基础来看，就像我们过去谈论的那样，但你有某些时候，你处于状态中，而你有其他时候，你……
on our team a lot for, you know, let's look at more junior people because, you know, there are a lot of really talented junior people out there who are just looking for an opportunity. And, you know, part of the interview process is making sure that you have the right opportunity for them. But I also believe that taking a junior engineer and helping them sort of grow into that senior engineer thing on your team helps them be really productive and really good at their role. And also, you know, a very good fit for coming up in the culture and the situation and the team. If you bring in a senior person, in some ways it's good because they're bringing a lot of experiences, but they're bringing on a certain amount of inertia and almost you want to say baggage or whatever they're bringing a direction that they're
在我们的团队中，我们经常会考虑招聘更多初级人员，因为有很多非常有才华的初级人员正在寻找机会。面试过程的一部分就是确保你为他们提供了合适的机会。但我同样认为，招募一名初级工程师并帮助他们成长为团队中的高级工程师，能让他们在岗位上变得非常高效且出色。同时，他们也能很好地融入团队文化和工作环境。如果你引入一名高级人员，从某些方面来说是好的，因为他们带来了丰富的经验，但他们也带来了一定的惯性，甚至可以说是包袱，或者说他们习惯了某种特定的工作方向和做事方式。
used to heading and that they think things ought to be done and sometimes that's good but if you have enough of those on your team adding more voices often can slow us down a little bit as you quibble more and re-digging up the why does your team use four spaces instead of two spaces for indentation or not tabs right because this person is going to bring in maybe rightfully so as a senior engineer they come in and they start to question things but that's not always what you want yeah i think this article is super interesting i like that point where you know looking at it at a per hour basis like we've talked about this in the past but you have you know certain times where you know looking at it at a per hour basis like we've talked about this in the past but you have you know certain times where you're kind of in the zone and you have other times where you
有时这固然是好事，但如果团队中这类人太多，增加更多的声音往往会拖慢我们的进度，因为大家会纠结于琐事，比如重新讨论为什么团队要用四个空格而不是两个空格来缩进，或者为什么不用制表符。因为作为一名高级工程师，他们可能会理直气壮地质疑这些事情，但这并不总是你想要的。是的，我觉得这篇文章非常有意思，我喜欢那个观点，即按小时来衡量效率，就像我们过去讨论过的那样，有些时候你处于专注状态，而有些时候你则不然。
just can't really be you can't be in the zone eight hours a day just banging out code i mean almost nobody can do that and so you are either going to spend that time on you know twitter or you're going to spend that time mentoring a junior engineer? So I feel like, uh, the idea of saying, Oh, you know, it's taking away time and money from the company. I don't know if that really, that really holds water. No, but I, I mean, I think it is something, and we were talking about this unrelatedly before the show, but I mean, I think it is one of those things where you have to be careful about what the, how to do well at your job. And if your company doesn't sort of see mentoring as something good,
你真的没法做到每天八小时都处于专注状态，不停地写代码，几乎没人能做到。所以你要么把时间花在推特上，要么花在指导初级工程师身上。我觉得那种说“这会占用公司时间和金钱”的观点，我不知道是否真的站得住脚。不，但我认为这确实是……我们在节目开始前也聊过这个，虽然和主题无关，但我认为你确实需要注意如何做好你的工作。如果你的公司不认为指导他人是一件好事，
which is very rare. I feel that even if companies don't have an explicit mentoring program or a concept of that or bringing a new person up to speed, that I've almost always found by being a person who helps the new people and teaches them like has worked out well for me. Um, it has been something that my managers end up respecting that, uh, you know, their managers end up, you know, realizing, and that the people on your team sort of know how you, that's an easier thing to deal with because you, you sort of taught them your view of what the team culture is and how the code review process works. So it's sort of someone who
这其实非常少见。我觉得即使公司没有明确的指导计划，或者没有培养新人的概念，我发现通过帮助新人并教导他们，对我自己来说一直很有成效。这最终会得到经理的尊重，他们会意识到这一点，团队成员也会了解你的处事方式。这更容易处理，因为你向他们传授了你对团队文化的理解以及代码审查流程是如何运作的。所以，这就像是有人
ends up being in my mind, almost more compatible with you, uh, going forward and having a good working relationship. So I've never had an issue where I felt like mentoring someone was, you know, wasting time. Yeah, definitely. I mean, even in, you know, Silicon Valley where, you know wasting time yeah definitely i mean even in you know silicon valley where you know the average person only stays was it two and a half years or something at one job yeah even then it's still valuable so i mean if you're at a company where the tenure is is longer than that then it gets it gets even more valuable right yeah and and i've always appreciated when people senior to me you know take time to to mentor me and to help um i kind of wish it happened more i really wish there was
最终在我的心目中，与你更加契合，能够共同前进并建立良好的工作关系。所以我从来没觉得指导别人是在浪费时间。是的，绝对是。即使在硅谷，普通人在一家公司只待两年半左右，即便如此，这依然很有价值。所以如果你所在公司的员工任期更长，那就更有价值了。我一直很感激那些比我资深的人花时间指导我、帮助我。我真希望这种情况能多发生一些，我真的很希望有
more of a culture of you know teaching and learning but yeah i think it's difficult it's difficult any company to really pull that off you have to have sort of really good inter-company communication and and the thing is it's not just having that communication but it's preventing a few people from kind of monopolizing it one of the things i've learned not to go on too much of a tangent is you want to have like really specialized channels of communication like we set up a machine learning noobs forum and that works really really well and so you might ask yourself well we had a you know we had an engineering of communication. Like we set up a machine learning noobs forum and that worked really, really well. And so you might ask yourself, well, we had a, you know, we had an engineering noobs
更多的教学和学习文化。但这很难，在任何公司实现这一点都很难。你必须拥有非常好的公司内部沟通机制。而且关键不仅在于沟通，还在于防止少数人垄断沟通。我学到的一点是——不想跑题太远——你想要有非常专业的沟通渠道。比如我们建立了一个“机器学习新手论坛”，效果非常好。你可能会问，我们不是已经有一个工程……沟通渠道了吗？比如我们建立了一个“机器学习新手论坛”，效果非常好。所以你可能会问，我们不是已经有一个工程新手
forum and noobs for people who don't know is like for newbies or new people. But in our case, it was literally just, you ask a question about machine learning. Like you didn't have to be brand new to machine learning or anything. And, you know, we had engineering noobs. So the question is like well why didn't that just vacuum all the questions away from machine learning noobs right and the reality is you know there's a a few people or a few types of questions that kind of just dominated that forum right and then when you get even more broad to like you know a forum with everybody who's in this office in a city or something then it's just a couple of things will monopolize almost any forum regardless of the size and uh
论坛了吗？“新手”对不知道的人来说就是指新人。但在我们这里，它字面上就是让你问关于机器学习的问题。你不必是机器学习的初学者。我们还有“工程新手”论坛。所以问题是，为什么它没有把机器学习新手论坛里的问题都吸走呢？现实情况是，确实有少数人或少数类型的问题主导了那个论坛。当你把范围扩大到整个办公室或城市里的所有人时，无论规模大小，总会有那么几件事垄断几乎所有的论坛。
um and so you know getting the right channel i think will help the the mentor thing a lot but it's it's not it's not trivial to get right. All right. The last news item is Detectron, which is pretty cool. So I shared a news a few months back of a GitHub repository that came with a nice tutorial for training like a mask RCNN network. And so the idea is like you give it some images and it would train and it would be able to find the items on the page and stuff like that. This is similar. The cool thing about this is they already have some models already trained. So if what you're looking for, if you want to build a robot or something else that can kind of find things in images. As long as those things are from
所以，找到正确的渠道我认为对指导工作很有帮助，但这并不容易做到。好了，最后一个新闻是 Detectron，它非常酷。几个月前我分享过一个 GitHub 仓库，里面有一个很好的教程，教你如何训练像 Mask RCNN 这样的网络。它的想法是，你给它一些图片，它就能进行训练，并能识别页面上的物品等等。这个也类似。它酷的地方在于它已经有一些训练好的模型了。所以如果你想制造一个机器人或其他能识别图片中物体的设备，只要这些物体在
the set and you can search through the set of categories, I think there's something like a million categories, then you could just use one of these off-the-shelf models. You don't have to train it or anything. So if you wanted to write something to detect, you know, dogs versus hot dogs or something like that um you could just use this off the shelf and uh it would just work i mean it would also tell you other things but you could just throw those away um but it would tell you you know where the dogs are and stuff like that um so it's pretty cool if you need to do any kind of image processing if you want to build your own like paintball gun turret or something crazy um check
它的集合里，而且你可以在那一百万个类别中搜索，你就可以直接使用这些现成的模型。你根本不需要训练它。所以如果你想写一个程序来检测狗和热狗之类的东西，你可以直接使用现成的模型，它就能直接工作。它当然也会告诉你其他东西，但你可以直接忽略它们。它会告诉你狗在哪里之类的。所以如果你需要做任何图像处理，或者想制造自己的彩弹枪炮塔之类的疯狂东西，去看看
out this detector on the screen it's time for book of the show it is book of the show it's been so long we're so excited it's we're reuniting um my book this show is basic economics by thomas soul and uh you know i talked again a few months back about um you know i tried to build this economics type simulator and and uh um you know i was using some pretty sophisticated machine learning but i just couldn't really get it to work and it turns out after reading this book i know nothing about economics. Or at least, you know, I thought I knew stuff about economics and I really didn't. This book is, I think it's like pretty standard reading for if you're in economics, like, you know, undergraduate or something like that. The cool thing is, and it even talks about this in the very first, like, preamble of the book. The very first sentence is, you know, you're not going to find any graphs.
这个 Detectron。现在是节目推荐书环节。没错，是节目推荐书环节。好久没做了，我们很兴奋，我们重聚了。我推荐的书是托马斯·索维尔的《经济学基础》。几个月前我提到过，我尝试建立一个经济模拟器，我用了一些相当复杂的机器学习，但我真的没法让它运行起来。结果读了这本书后，我发现我对经济学一窍不通。或者至少，我以为我懂一些经济学，但其实并没有。我认为这本书是经济学本科生的标准读物。最酷的是，书的序言里就提到了，第一句话就是：你在这本书里找不到任何图表。
You're not going to find any equations. This is just about the principles of economics. It's written in very lay terms, so you don't have to be an economist or anything like that. It's really fascinating. It has some really in-depth case studies on planned economies so for people who know that's where the government or or someone sets the prices um so in a sense uh um like uh garbage or maybe not garbage but uh like like minimum wage jobs are a sense of planned economy all right so if you work a job that's a minimum wage job, the government, as they change the minimum
你找不到任何方程式。这讲的只是经济学原理。它用非常通俗的语言写成，所以你不必是经济学家也能看懂。它非常引人入胜。书中对计划经济有一些非常深入的案例研究，对于了解的人来说，那就是政府或某人设定价格的地方。从某种意义上说，垃圾处理，或者也许不是垃圾，比如最低工资工作，也是一种计划经济。所以如果你从事的是最低工资的工作，政府在改变最低
wage, they're changing how much money you're making. That's a planned economy. Unless there's a massive shortage of your job, and then it's not minimum wage anymore. But it talks all about these different planned economies, both like massive, large scale planned economies that they had kind of decades ago in India and the Soviet Union, things like that. But also, you know, like local, you know, microeconomic sense, like local planned economies and basically like why they're all bad. So the book definitely has a slant towards, you know, pure laissez-faire free market economics. But, you know, you obviously have to take that into account while you're reading it. But it talks all about these different economies.
工资时，他们就在改变你的收入。这就是计划经济。除非你的工作岗位极度短缺，那样就不再是最低工资了。但书中讨论了所有这些不同的计划经济，既有几十年前印度和苏联那种大规模的计划经济，也有微观经济意义上的，比如地方性的计划经济，以及为什么它们都很糟糕。这本书确实倾向于纯粹的自由放任市场经济，你在阅读时显然需要考虑到这一点。但它讨论了所有这些不同的经济体。
And it really explained things that I just didn't really understand. You know, I was like, how does this thing cost so much? Why does this cost so little? Why is this happening? Why is that happening? It really kind of, it covers a lot of really interesting topical cases. And these are just core things that as a society, we get wrong over and over again. And it even talks about why we keep getting them wrong.
它真的解释了我以前不理解的事情。我以前会想，为什么这个东西这么贵？为什么那个这么便宜？为什么会发生这种情况？为什么会发生那种情况？它涵盖了很多非常有趣的专题案例。这些都是我们作为一个社会反复犯错的核心问题。它甚至讨论了为什么我们一直犯错。
It has to do with, you know, it's just easy to convince a lot of people to do the wrong thing and they'll love you for it. But it covers a lot of different scenarios. It's really, really interesting. Just to explain, like, the simulation that I had, you know, it didn't work for two reasons. One, actually, part of it was working. I didn't realize there's going to be some agents who are just going to fail. So, so part of having a good economy is that there needs to be sort of businesses that fail and businesses that succeed. And there has to be sort of some risk. And the consequence of the risk is, you know, you go
这与……很容易说服很多人去做错误的事情，而他们还会因此而爱你。但它涵盖了许多不同的场景。真的非常非常有趣。解释一下我那个模拟器，它没成功有两个原因。第一，其实有一部分是成功的。我没意识到会有一些注定要失败的代理。所以，拥有一个良好经济体系的一部分是，必须有失败的企业，也有成功的企业。必须存在一定的风险。而风险的后果就是，你破产了。
bankrupt. Um, if no one's going bankrupt, the economy is not really working. It means people can't really take any chances. And the other part of it is there needs to be a whole network of alternatives. So in my case, there were several businesses, but they're all doing the same thing in my little simulation. And so people couldn't say, oh, the price of bread went up, I'm going to buy carrots instead. And so without alternatives, the economic system doesn't really make any sense.
如果没人破产，经济就不是真正地在运作。这意味着人们无法真正承担任何风险。另一个原因是，需要有一个完整的替代方案网络。在我的案例中，有几家企业，但它们在我的小模拟里都在做同样的事情。所以人们不能说，“哦，面包价格涨了，我要去买胡萝卜”。所以没有替代方案，经济系统就没有任何意义。
And there's, I mean, I could talk for a whole hour. There's a whole bunch going on here, but you don't need to have a super strong background in economics. Definitely read it if these are things that are interesting. And it's a pretty long book. i haven't got through it all but even if you just read the first couple of chapters it would be worth it economics is always one of those things where i think a lot of people underestimate um how how good it is as explaining a lot of stuff that happens.
我真的可以讲上整整一个小时。这里面有很多内容，但你不需要有很强的经济学背景。如果这些内容让你感兴趣，一定要读读。这是一本很厚的书。我还没读完，但即使只读前几章也值得。经济学总是那种我认为很多人低估了它在解释许多事情方面有多么出色。
But then there are sometimes people who overestimate, you know, what economic theories can predict. And so it's one of those really, I've only ever studied economics at a very small level. And so there's a lot of things like you're explaining. These actually seem very fascinating. But then at some point, it's always difficult to map back. Like, you know, like you said, oh, every time there's been a planned economy, it's failed. It's like, but, you know, such statements always seem like, you know, very difficult to make. Absolutely.
但有时也有人高估了经济理论的预测能力。所以，我只在很浅的层面上研究过经济学。所以你解释的很多事情看起来非常迷人。但在某些时候，总是很难映射回去。就像你说的，每一次计划经济都失败了。但这种说法总是让人觉得很难下定论。绝对是。
Yeah, you're totally right you know what i mean i yeah it feels like one of those you know they say you know this science of economics i don't know if you would call it a science or not but just like the study of economics always seems a little hard for me because it wants to make these absolutes but you really can't because it's all about at some level all about humans and it's very difficult to make absolute statements about human behavior yeah and even if you did you know there's there's sort of a heisenberg principle here right like if you tell everyone look x is bad then everyone will stop doing x but then that will change the whole dynamics of the whole system like by virtue of everyone not doing x maybe x becomes good you know so so there's all sorts of
是的，你说得完全对。我的意思是，这感觉就像是……人们说经济学是一门科学，我不知道你是否会称之为科学，但经济学研究对我来说总是有点难，因为它想做出这些绝对的结论，但你真的做不到，因为它在某种程度上全是关于人类的，而对人类行为做出绝对的陈述是非常困难的。是的，即使你做了，这里也存在某种海森堡测不准原理，对吧？如果你告诉每个人“X 是坏的”，那么每个人都会停止做 X，但这会改变整个系统的动态。也许因为每个人都不做 X，X 反而变成了好事。所以这里面有各种各样的
weirdness going on you need game theory too so you got to be a economics expert and game theory and yeah i mean it's all kind of tied together yeah um yeah so i would say you know the book this person has a lot of strong opinions you know i i definitely don't agree with all of it but i learned a incredible amount so has it changed what you're going to vote for in the next election no it's okay no i'm just oh i have no idea um i could tell you that uh rent control doesn't work um that has been proven and they actually they just uh passed rent control in mountain view which is a city right next to where we live um and uh this book talks all about all the places in the u.s that have passed rent control and explicitly like what happens and
怪事。你还需要博弈论，所以你得是经济学专家和博弈论专家。是的，这一切都是相互关联的。所以我认为这本书的作者有很多强烈的观点，我肯定不同意其中的所有内容，但我学到了非常多。那么这改变了你在下次选举中的投票意向吗？不，没关系。我不知道，我完全没头绪。我可以告诉你，租金管制是行不通的，这已经被证明了。他们刚刚在山景城通过了租金管制，那是我们住的地方旁边的一个城市。这本书讨论了美国所有通过租金管制的地方，以及明确发生了什么，
it just doesn't work and it's not one of those things where it can't work or it just hasn't worked i think um i think i would say that it can't work. Basically, I'll tell you quickly what happens is people just start hedging the rent control, right? So they say, well, if I can lock in a good rent, then, you know, I have a kid. My kid's 10 years old. Eight years from now, he'll be 18. Let me just get an apartment and rent it at you know whatever the controlled price is now and that way if the price goes up then my son can live in this apartment when he's
它就是行不通。这并不是说它不能行得通，或者只是还没行得通，我认为它就是行不通。基本上，我快速告诉你发生了什么，人们开始规避租金管制。他们会说，如果我能锁定一个好的租金，我有孩子，他现在 10 岁，8 年后他就 18 岁了。让我现在就租一套公寓，按受控价格租下来，这样如果价格上涨，我儿子长大后就能住进这套公寓。
of age right um and so you end up with just massive uh vacancy which is what you have in san francisco and in new york city actually um and uh and he just said you know every time they've done rent control uh you end up with with huge vacancy rates now there's a question of like is vacancy rate the right metric for success um you know i don't know well but i mean couldn't you but it's always one of the things where people feel they're different so you know mountain view just enacts rent control but oh but we're different or we're doing it this time or we introduce this tiny slight difference where you know basically if it's vacant then you know you lose the rent control or something right like you could always try a slight variation on it
所以你最终会得到巨大的空置率，这正是旧金山和纽约市的情况。他说，每一次他们实行租金管制，你最终都会得到巨大的空置率。现在的问题是，空置率是衡量成功的正确指标吗？我不知道。但人们总是觉得他们的情况不同。所以山景城刚刚实施了租金管制，但他们会说“我们不同”或者“我们这次会做得不一样”，或者我们引入了这个微小的差异，比如如果房子空置了，你就失去了租金管制之类的。你总是可以尝试稍微变通一下，
uh or it'd be different this time if that makes sense i don't know yeah i know what you're saying um yeah i mean maybe you know i mean i mean obviously the more like uh the more restrictive you make the allocation of rent control the closer it's going to get to a freer market so there's some gradient there but yeah i mean who knows it's a good question i mean this is the uh well what is his name oh oh man now this is the, uh, well, what is his name? Oh, oh man, now this is going to bother me. Uh, Nassim Tlaib, the black swan. I think it's a black swan is where he talks about this is the, you know, the Turkey befriends the farmer. I've probably told this story before. I don't know. It's actually his story. I've never heard it. Oh, okay. The, the, the Turkey's on the farm and, you know, every day
或者这次会不一样。我不知道。是的，我知道你的意思。也许吧，显然你对租金管制的分配限制越严格，它就越接近自由市场，所以这中间有一个梯度。但谁知道呢，这是一个好问题。这是……他的名字叫什么？天哪，这要困扰我了。纳西姆·塔勒布，《黑天鹅》。我想是在《黑天鹅》里他谈到了这个，火鸡与农夫的故事。我可能以前讲过这个故事。我不知道。这其实是他的故事。我从没听过。哦，好吧。火鸡在农场里，每天
the, the sort of Turkey sees the farmer and, you know, the farmer feeds him. And so the Turkey goes, wow, this, this farmer is my friend. And, you know, oh, this farmer is my friend. And this goes on for, you know, like a year and the, you know, Turkey's completely convinced that this farmer intends me no harm, that he's my friend. And then one day it happens to be, you know, the day before Thanksgiving and the farmer is not the friend of the turkey. And it's like, you know, everything's the same. And you can come up with, you know, hey, look, every time we've done this, it shows that the farmer is my friend. And then one day it just isn't.
火鸡看到农夫，农夫喂它。所以火鸡想：“哇，这个农夫是我的朋友。”这持续了一年，火鸡完全确信农夫对我没有恶意，他是我的朋友。然后有一天，正好是感恩节前一天，农夫就不是火鸡的朋友了。一切都一样。你可以说：“嘿，看，每次我们这样做，都证明农夫是我的朋友。”然后有一天，它就不是了。
Yeah, I see your point. And so, like it just isn't. Yeah, I see your point. And so like you can say, oh, I have a model. I have an understanding. I have my Bayesian prior until none of it works. You know, and I hope it's hit that book. And the reason why I say I think it is
是的，我明白你的意思。所以你可以说，我有一个模型，我有一种理解，我有我的贝叶斯先验，直到这一切都不起作用。我希望它能击中那本书。我之所以这么说，是因为基本上这就是黑天鹅。没人相信黑天鹅存在，因为每个人都只见过白天鹅。所以世界上只有白天鹅，天鹅只能是白色的。然后有人发现了一只黑天鹅，他们就说：“哦，好吧，黑天鹅。”是的，完全正确。这是一个好问题，但我认为这就是为什么经济系统不断失败的原因。所以这是另一件事，我们基本上每七年就会经历一次大崩盘。但即便如此，经济中也存在这些微小的失败。
is because basically that's the black swan. Nobody believed black swans existed because everyone had only ever seen white swans right so there are only white swans in the world the only color swan can be can be white and then someone finds a black swan and they're like oh okay black swans yeah exactly yeah i mean it's a good question i mean i think but to your point that's why economic systems are constantly failing. So that's another thing is, you know, there's just, I mean, we've seen basically every seven years there's some big crash. But then even then there's these micro failures in the economy.
有时他们不得不……就像书里谈到的，委内瑞拉三分之一的石油出了问题。石油本身没问题，但定价被抬高了。一群世界贸易组织的人不得不介入，开始手动处理。比如这个人保证购买石油，然后他们取消了保证，没有任何惩罚。他们基本上不得不手动在这些人之间进行仲裁，因为系统已经崩溃了。所以，是的。好吧，我的书没那么严肃。
And sometimes they have to sort of, like they talk about in this book, like one third of Venezuela's oil was like just messed up. Like, I mean, the oil was fine, but just the pricing just got jacked up. And a bunch of like World Trade Organization people had to basically just step in and start doing manual things. Like this person was, you know, guaranteed to buy this oil. And then they just like canceled the guarantee without any penalty. They basically had to like do this arbitration among all these people manually because the system had just failed. So, yeah. Well, my book is nothing so serious.
这是一本科幻小说。我推荐很多硬科幻，或者你称之为深度长篇科幻。你对世界构建之类的东西很感兴趣，而这一本完全不是那样。这是约翰·斯卡尔齐的《模糊国度》。我以前推荐过他的书，这实际上是一本旧书的重述，只是更新了，变得更新颖。我没读过那本旧书，所以我对它一无所知，除了序言里提到这是为现代读者重述的旧科幻故事。
It's a science fiction book. And I recommend a lot of hard sci-fi or you know sci-fi that's like i guess you would call it deep long form sure you're very interested in kind of the world building stuff or whatever and this one is not like that at all uh so this is fuzzy nation by john scalzi i've recommended uh books of his before uh and this is actually a retelling of a older book um just sort of like updated and made made newer i haven't read that older book, so I don't know anything about it other than in the sort of preface they discussed that, oh, this is a retelling of a older sci-fi story for modern times.
这是一个关于未来某个人在不同星球上发生有趣事情的故事。它围绕着人、公司、星球以及星球上的一些原生生物之间的互动展开。关于……当我说是“一个问题”时，它不是那种发人深省的深度思考，它只是一个关于“什么是感知或生命”或者“作为人类我们应该如何对待事物”的轻松故事。它不是在质问，而是在玩味这个概念。所以我推荐它，这是一本非常容易读的书，或者至少
And it's a story about a person who is some amount of time into the future, you know, on a different planet some interesting things happening um but it it sort of pivots around the interactions of uh the people and the companies and the planet and some of the native species of the planet and a question about just like how and when i say a question it's not like some deep thought provoking oh i really wonder it's just a light-hearted story about kind of like what what does it mean to be sentient or alive or how should we treat you know things as humans and it's not asking it's just a play on that i should say rather than questioning it um and so i'd recommend it it's a very easy read or at least
我发现它非常轻松愉快。因为我是听书而不是看书，所以容易读也容易听。你不需要那种“刚才发生了什么？我真的得集中注意力”的感觉。它很有趣，有时很傻，很幽默。
i found it to be very lighthearted and easy. And since I listened to it, not read it, I guess, easy read and easy listened, you didn't have to like sort of, oh, what was happening there? I really have to focus. You know, you can just sort of, it's kind of fun and goofy and humorous at times.
所以这就是约翰·斯卡尔齐的《模糊国度》。酷。是的，我也听了《经济学基础》，或者说还在听。哦，好吧，还在听《经济学基础》。我们在 Audible 上听。这算作弊吗？我觉得我应该说“读过”，但我觉得这是正确的做法。好吧，我觉得说“读过”没问题，只是太容易混淆了。我们应该问问 Audible 的人。所以，如果你想听这些书并告诉别人你读过它们，你可以看看 Audible。
So that's Fuzzy Nation by John Scalzi. Cool. Yeah, I also listened to the Basic Economics or still listening to it. Oh, okay. And basic economics are still listening to it okay and uh yeah we're listening to it on audible yeah is that cheating i feel like i just say red but it's because i think it's the right thing to do okay yeah i think red is fine it's just too confusing yeah we should we should ask the folks at audible so um yeah if you uh if you want to listen to these books and tell people you read them, you can check out Audible.
你去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。我们在节目笔记里有链接。如果你通过我们去，我想你可以免费获得第一本书。是这样吗？是的，第一个月免费。我们也从 A 那里得到感谢，这对我们来说真的很棒，有助于维持服务器的运行。如果你已经有 Audible 或者
You go to audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown. And we have a link to that in the show notes. And if you go through us, I think you get your first book free. Is that right? Yes. First month is free. And we also get a thank you from A which uh which is really great for us and helps keep the the server lights on on the servers um we're also if you already have audible or you
想以其他方式捐赠，我们有 Patreon。顺便说一下，我们有一个自定义的 Patreon RSS，我从没在节目里提过，我提过一点点，它在 Patreon 页面上。下载速度更快，正常运行时间也稍微好一点。所以如果你去 Patreon 捐赠，我想最低是一美元，你就可以访问那个超快的 RSS 源，下载速度会更快。
want to donate in a different way we have patreon um we have a custom patreon rss by the way i haven't ever mentioned this on a show i've talked about it a little bit i mean it's on the patreon page but uh the downloads are faster um the uptime is a little bit. I mean, it's on the Patreon page, but the downloads are faster. The uptime is a little bit better. So if you go on Patreon and give, I think the minimum is a dollar, you can get access to the really fast RSS feed and get the downloads a little bit quicker.
我们……更新一下，也许我们可以晚点再说，但对于那些……我们说过新年时所有 Patreon 会员都会得到一个编程 Throwdown 的徽章之类的东西，我不知道怎么称呼它，像激光切割的东西。我正盯着厨房桌子上的一大堆东西。不错。我们做了一些试运行。我想说我们遇到了一些制造困难，这就是杰森和我不得不比预期更多地迭代的原因。我以为这会很容易，会很棒。结果证明这就是 Kickstarter 很难的原因，这甚至不是
And we, just an update, I guess we could do it later, but for the people people we had said everyone who was patreon at the new year was going to get a little programming throwdown badge thing i don't know what you call it like a laser cut thing i am staring at a giant stack of them sitting on my kitchen table nice um so we did a couple of trial runs yeah i was gonna say we ran into some manufacturing difficulties that's what jason and i had to iterate this more than i anticipated we were going to have to i thought oh this will be easy it'll be great and yeah it turns out this is why kickstarters are hard and this wasn't even
一个 Kickstarter 项目。没人写信问“嘿，我的东西在哪？”所以，是的，感谢你们的耐心。非常感谢。是的，大规模生产东西确实很难。
a kickstarter and people aren't even you know anyways yeah i mean nobody's really written in saying hey where's my uh you know uh like, where's my thing? And so. Yes. Thank you for your patience. Yeah. Thank you a lot for that. Yeah. Definitely mass producing things is hard.
你知道，感谢 Cafe Press 为我们代发 T 恤。他们有那套系统。但对我们来说，这是一年一次的事情，所以我们没有真正的系统，但我们会完成它的。我们经历了一些制造问题，但最新的一批很稳固。是的，当我们说制造问题时，意思是当杰森制作设计，我用激光切割它们，然后我邮寄给他，弄清楚塑料应该多厚，以及如何邮寄才不会裂开，
You know, props to Cafe Press for drop shipping our T-shirts. Yeah. They have like, you know, the system. But, you know, for us, it's like once a year thing. So we don't have a real system in place but we're gonna get it done we went through some manufacturing issues but the latest uh set has been has been solid yes and so we say manufacturing issues what we mean is like when i when jason makes the design and i laser cut them and then i mail them to him and working out that like how thick the plastic should be and how do we mail it so that it doesn't crack
这样你们收到的不是一堆塑料碎片，而是漂亮的编程 Throwdown 标志。所以，这很有趣。我们应该谈谈它，我会写下来的。这确实很有趣，我有所有的照片，我们应该做一个博客之类的文章。但我确实有……这是什么？大约 25% 的东西还在我的厨房台面上。所以我很快就会把它们寄给你。非常酷。节目工具。哦，抱歉。
on the you know so that you guys don't get just like bits of plastic instead of a nice programming throwdown logo so exactly it's been fun well we should talk about it so i'm going to write it up anyways it is kind of interesting i have all the pictures we should make like uh like a little kind of blog type post about yeah but i do but I do have, what is this? This is about 25% of them are more sitting on my kitchen counter. So I'll be sending them your way shortly. Very cool. Tool of the show. Oh, sorry.
我的节目工具是 hyper.js。我当时在做一些 Arduino 的工作，我们稍后会谈到。我想要一个好的 Windows 设置。我也在做一些树莓派的工作之类的。我有 Windows 的 Ubuntu bash。我不知道你管它叫什么。就是 Ubuntu 在 Windows 内部运行，但它仍然在 Windows 命令行应用中运行，那并不太好。
My tool of the show is hyper.js. So I was doing some work on Arduino, which we'll talk about later. And I wanted to have a good Windows setup. And I was also doing some Raspberry Pi work and stuff like that. And I have the Ubuntu bash for Windows thing. I don't know really what you call it. But the thing where it's like Ubuntu is running inside of Windows, but it still runs in the Windows command know command line app which is not that great
我发现了这个 hyper.js，它非常酷。它基本上是用 JavaScript 实现的，基于 Electron 构建，现在很多应用都是这样构建的，所以它们可以是跨平台的。而且，它就是一个超级超级好的终端。它有标签页，有多个窗口，所有你期望从一个好的终端得到的东西它都有。关键是，你可以在任何东西上使用它。所以如果你学会了快捷键
um and i found this hyper.js it's really really cool it's basically it it's all implemented in javascript uh it's built on electron uh which is what you know a lot of apps nowadays are built in so they could be kind of cross-platform and And, you know, it's just a super, super nice terminal. It has tabs, it has multiple windows, all the things you kind of expect from like a really nice terminal. And the thing is, you can use this on anything. So kind of if you learn the shortcuts
以及它是如何工作的，这些知识可以应用到任何机器上。你可以在 Mac 上，在 Windows 上，在 Linux 上，HyperJS 在所有平台上都能运行。它超级超级酷。我实际上在考虑把它作为我的默认终端。我现在在工作中使用 iTerm，我在家里用这个。
and how it works and stuff like that, you know, that knowledge will carry over to any machine. You could be on Mac, you could be on Windows, you could be on Linux, HybridJS works on everything. It's super, super cool. I'm actually thinking about trying to make it my defacto terminal. I use iTerm right now at work, and I'm using this at home.
在家里的一些电脑上，我还在运行 GNOME 终端。我正在考虑直接全面转向 HyperJS。但到目前为止，我真的很喜欢它。我知道，我想我记得当它刚出来或流行起来时，人们在抱怨，
And on a couple of the computers at home, I'm still running the GNOME terminal. I'm thinking about just taking the plunge and just doing HyperJS for everything. But so far, I'm really liking it. I know that, I think I recall when this first came out or gained popularity, and people were sort of complaining that,
“看，从你敲击键盘到字母出现在屏幕上需要多长时间。”我知道他们对 Atom 也有同样的抱怨，Atom 是一个基于 Electron 的文本编辑器，说它慢且有问题。是的，那其实已经修复了。我正想说，是的，他们确实修复了。
oh, look how long it takes from when you type or punch a button on your keyboard to when the letter appears on the screen. And I know they have the same complaints about Atom, which is an electron-based text editor, about being slow and problematic. Yeah, that's actually fixed. Yeah, I was going to say, yeah, well, they did fix it.
但在那之前，这是一个合理的抱怨。是的，我看到了 GitHub 上的问题，有些问题仍然是开放的。但基本上，他们做了很多后台工作。我不知道具体细节，我知道他们做的一件事是编写了自己的终端模拟器，而不是使用 Google Chrome 内置的那个叫 h term 的东西。那个很慢。他们用别的东西替换了它。
But before it was a legitimate complaint. Yeah, i saw the you know github issues like kind of complaints about it like some of the github issues are still open um but basically yeah they they just did a bunch of work on the back i mean i don't know specific i know one of the things they did is they wrote their own terminal emulator instead of i guess there's this thing called h term that's built into Google Chrome. And that was slow. They replaced it with something else.
但是的，你会在博客上看到那些问题。但我没觉得那是个问题了。好吧，我想说的是，我用过 Atom，有更快的工具。我没试过这个，但我认为很大程度上取决于个人，所以不要因为糟糕的博客文章就放弃尝试。像任何事情一样，你得自己试试。是的，那也是真的。我没在它慢的时候试过，也许它现在还是很慢，我只是不在乎。我想说的是，也许这些东西很慢，但我用的电脑足够快，所以不困扰我。就像我倾向于在
But yeah, you're going to see those issues on blogs and things like that. But I haven't found that to be a problem anymore. Well, yeah, what I was going to say is like I've used Atom and there are faster things. I've not tried this, but i think a lot of it just depends so i wouldn't be dissuaded off of stuff just because of bad blog posts like anything you got to try yourself yeah that's true too i mean i didn't try it when it was slower i mean maybe it's it's still slow i just don't care that's what i was gonna say is maybe this stuff is slow and i just run on fast enough computers that it doesn't bother me yeah like i tend to run on
配置相当不错的电脑上运行，比如文本编辑，但我可以想象，这是一个合理的抱怨。没有理由文本编辑器要占用那么多内存。但对大多数人来说，这可能根本不重要。是的，我会说，HyperJS 全是 JavaScript 和 HTML。所以，换句话说，如果你在键盘上按 L，它实际上是在更新某个 HTML 组件。所以，是的，那会比任何其他终端慢得多。但它是完全无法察觉的。会困扰我的事情是，如果我运行一个命令，它生成了无限量的输出，我不得不杀掉它，而那个命令杀不掉。那会非常令人沮丧。但我测试过了。
computers that are quite well specced i guess for stuff like text editing but i can imagine i mean it's a legitimate complaint like there is no reason a text editor has to take that much ram um but for most people it probably just doesn't matter. Yeah, I mean, I will say, you know, HyperJS, it's all JavaScript and HTML. So, you know, in other words, if you press L on the keyboard, you know, it's actually updating some HTML component. And so, yeah, that's going to be way slower than any other terminal. But, I mean, it's completely imperceptible. I mean, things that would bother me would be if I ran a command that generated, let's say, effectively an infinite amount of output and I had to kill it and that command wouldn't die. That would be really frustrating. But I tested this out.
我做了一个 find /，它会列出我硬盘上的每一个文件。我杀掉它时，它是瞬间停止的。所以，我没遇到任何问题。酷。我的节目工具，基于之前的制造缺陷，是我有一个激光切割机。这是一个来自中国的非常低端的切割机，叫 K40。通常你必须安装……这就是为什么我甚至没比我最终购买的时间更早买它，我真的很喜欢它，它对我来说工作得很好，尽管它有很多注意事项，还有人们的东西着火的故事。所以总是把灭火器放在附近，
I did like a find slash where it's just going to list every single file on my hard drive. And I killed it, you know, instantly. So, yeah, I haven't had any issues cool uh my tool of the show based on the previous manufacturing defect thing is that i have a laser cutter uh it is a very low-end uh cutter from china called the k40 and normally you have to install which is why i actually didn't buy it even sooner than i did end up buying which i've really liked and it's worked well for me although there are tons of caveats around it and stories of people's stuff catching on fire so always keep my fire extinguisher near
永远不要让它无人看管。好吧，事实证明，如果你用激光切割东西，它会产生烟雾，这些烟雾可能会点燃。是的，当然，你需要注意你在做什么，并有适当的排烟和吹气来分散烟雾，并留意它。好吧，那听起来真的很可怕。帕特里克为了我们的 Patreon 订阅者牺牲了他的生命。如果你要买激光切割机，要小心你切割的东西，因为有些东西切割时会释放有毒气体。但无论如何，有激光安全材料。长话短说，你应该用来运行它的软件，范围从“这怎么可能工作”到“安装这个我肯定会中病毒”。
um and never leave it unattended well it turns out if you're you know cutting stuff with a laser and like it makes fumes and those fumes could ignite like yeah of course like you need to watch what you're doing and have proper fume extraction and air blowing to disperse the fumes and keep an eye on it um okay that was really terrifying sounding patrick is is sacrificing his life for our patreon subscribers and be careful what you cut just if you're if you're going to get a laser cutter because some stuff you cut will release toxic gases um but there are laser safe materials anyways okay long story short the uh software that you're supposed to use to run this is like ranges from well is there any way this could possibly work to i'm definitely getting a virus from installing this
所以我真的不想那样做。你必须插入一个 USB 硬件加密狗来运行一些人所说的盗版软件，然后还有一个插件，这就像“哦，我真的不想折腾这个，为什么这这么难？”你基本上只需要用几个步进电机指向激光，然后打开它。但这些是为使用特定软件的人制造的，我想这实际上是说这是为了制作基于你中文名字的印章。但他们发现它们对业余爱好者来说通常很酷且有用，而且制作成本非常便宜。
and so i was really not wanting to do that and you have to like you know sort of plug in a usb hardware dongle to run what some people sort of say is like a counterfeit version of some software or a pirated version of some software and then there's a plug-in and it's just like oh i really don't want to be messing with this why why is this so hard like you basically have to just point the laser using a couple stepper motors and then turn it on correct but these these are made for people who use some specific software package to i think it's actually said that this is for making um sort of stamps based on your name in chinese um but they've just found out they're generally kind of cool and useful for hobbyists and they're really cheap to make.
所以它们被重新利用了，这是销售它们的公司的解决方案，但它不是很好。所以一个选择是你可以更换控制步进电机的控制器板，让它像 3D 打印机一样接收 G 代码。很多人这样做，我也考虑过这样做，因为你可以获得更多的控制权。当然，但你也可以做的是，有人基本上嗅探了协议，弄清楚了这个充满病毒的软件用键盘记录器在做什么。他们基本上弄清楚了它在做什么协议，并编写了
And so they've been sort of retasked and this is the, whatever company that sells them, this is their solution and it's just not very good. So instead one option is you could replace the controller board that controls the stepper motors to just take G code like a 3d printer would be um and there's lots of people who do that and i've considered doing that because you can actually get more control over it um sure but what you could also do is somebody basically sniffed the protocol and figured out what this definitely virus laden software was doing with keyloggers um They basically figured out what protocol it was doing and they wrote
一个非常简单的 UI。我的工作流程基本上是杰森制作图案，我想也许你用 Illustrator 或 Inkscape，我不知道。然后我在 Inkscape 中编辑它，使其成为我需要的样子，然后你把它导入到软件 K40 Whisperer 中。所以激光切割机的名字是 K40。这个家伙制作了这个免费软件，并提供了源代码，K40 Whisperer，它允许你控制激光并切割你的设计，而不必安装可怕的、不可知的软件。
a very simple UI where my workflow is basically Jason kind of makes the pattern and I think maybe you use Illustrator or Inkscape, I don't know. And then I sort of edited up an Inkscape to be sort of what I need and then you import it into the software K40 Whisperer. So the name of the laser cutter is K40. And this guy made this free software and has a source code for it, K40 Whisperer, that will allow you to control the laser and cut your designs without having to install horrible, unknowable software on it.
它太棒了。我真的很喜欢它。人们所做的事情然后免费发布，这太疯狂了。我总是很震惊，我想这个家伙是在业余时间编程，因为他不是……我正想说你会雇佣他吗？我不知道，我没看过代码，但我很感激他在做这项工作。是的，这说得通，尽管这是一件有趣的事情，我当时在想。
And it's been awesome. I've really liked it. And it's crazy what people do and then just sort of like release for free i'm always sort of yeah this is nuts i'm always sort of you know shocked that i guess this guy is doing programming in his free time because he's not i was gonna say would you hire him i mean i don't know i've not looked at the software but i am appreciative that he's doing the work yeah it makes sense although it's an interesting thing i was thinking
这太棒了，我真的很喜欢。人们所做的事情以及他们愿意免费发布出来，这真是太疯狂了。我总是感到很震惊，我想这家伙是在业余时间编程，因为他不是……我本来想问你会雇佣他吗？我不知道，我没看过他的软件，但我很感激他所做的工作。是的，这很有道理，尽管这是一个有趣的事情，我当时正在思考。
about this because i think it's a quite difficult problem so we were talking about 3d printers the slicers um right most of the slicers are sort of free and so you i guess you get what you pay for at some level but um they do a lot of random things that seems like they should be able to do better and it is a really tricky problem but you know these are people doing this in their free time and a lot of them are probably i assume probably self-taught um and the complexity of the things they're doing is actually quite astonishing uh given those constraints but it's like wow it really seems like you ought to be doing better because there's often where you'll just get these movements where the print head or the laser cutter will just sort of like cut down in the bottom left
关于这一点，因为我觉得这是一个相当困难的问题。我们之前在谈论 3D 打印机和切片软件，对吧？大多数切片软件某种程度上是免费的，所以我想在某种程度上是一分钱一分货。但是，它们确实做了很多随机的事情，看起来它们本可以做得更好。这确实是一个非常棘手的问题，但你知道，这些人是在业余时间做这件事，而且我猜他们中的许多人可能是自学的。考虑到这些限制，他们所做事情的复杂性实际上相当令人惊讶。但感觉就像是，哇，看起来你真的应该做得更好，因为经常会出现这种情况：打印头或激光切割机会莫名其妙地切到左下角。
and then move all the way up to the top right and do a little more cutting and then move all the way back again. And it's like, huh, it really seems like you should have been able to run some optimization and not do that. I think you found your next side project. Oh, no, no, I keep thinking that.
然后一直移动到右上角，再切一点，然后再一路移回去。这让人觉得，哈，看起来你本应该能够运行一些优化，而不必那样做。我想你找到了下一个副业项目。哦，不，不，我一直在想那个。
I'm like, no, I bet this problem is way harder than I think. Yeah, so I won't fool myself but k40 whisper if you're in the very small minority of people listening who has a laser cutter and that laser cutter happens to be this thing and happens to be one of the ones compatible i would definitely check this out but you probably already know if you are but anyways shout out to to these guys this is amazing yeah very cool all right so we are going to try our best to cover arduino there's there's a lot to talk about um i mean we could go all day about maker whatever but um but yeah we'll talk about arduino kind of specifically and uh if you have any questions about any Maker stuff, just post on Facebook or anything like that. Yeah, so Arduino, I think a lot of people have probably heard about it. And Jason sort of said the kind of Maker movement or making things.
我在想，不，我敢打赌这个问题比我想象的要难得多。是的，所以我不会自欺欺人。但如果你是极少数拥有激光切割机的听众之一，而且那台激光切割机恰好是这种型号，又恰好是兼容的型号之一，我绝对会去看看这个软件。但如果你是的话，你可能已经知道了。总之，向这些人致敬，这太棒了。是的，非常酷。好了，我们要尽力介绍 Arduino，有很多东西要谈。我的意思是，我们可以整天谈论创客之类的东西，但我们会专门谈谈 Arduino。如果你对任何创客相关的东西有疑问，只需在 Facebook 或类似平台上发布即可。是的，关于 Arduino，我想很多人可能都听说过。Jason 刚才提到了创客运动或制作东西。
I mean, Arduino, I remember when it, you know, was sort of first coming out and people were, wow, what is this overpriced thing that is coming out of Italy and is, you know, underpowered, draws too much, you know, current and is sort of laughable. And that was sort of the people who did embedded programming, which is something I was involved in at the time, which is why I was sort of peripherally aware of this.
我的意思是，我记得 Arduino 刚出来的时候，人们说，哇，这是什么从意大利出来的价格过高的东西，动力不足，电流消耗太大，简直是个笑话。这大概是当时从事嵌入式编程的人的看法，这也是我当时参与的领域，所以我对此略有耳闻。
And in a lot of ways, they were right. Objectively, the Arduino shouldn't have worked. It was made by people who kind of didn't know, at least from reports that I can understand, they were students at the time. They kind of didn't know what they were doing, and they made a bunch of sort of, what would you call, I guess, like rookie mistakes
在很多方面，他们是对的。客观地说，Arduino 本不该成功。据我所能了解到的报道，它是由当时还是学生的人制作的，他们不太懂自己在做什么，并且犯了一堆所谓的，我想，新手错误。
in designing the PCB for Arduino, the sort of power adapters they've used. And then in what is, you know, a great show of it kind of often doesn't matter. It's not the best solution that wins all the time. And I guess Arduino hasn't won in that it's not by any means the most commonly shipped microcontroller but it almost in my estimation probably single-handedly created the the behemoth of using microcontrollers for this maker and hobbyist movement uh that it is
在设计 Arduino 的 PCB 和他们使用的电源适配器时。然后，在一个伟大的展示中，它证明了这往往并不重要。并不是最好的解决方案总是能获胜。我想 Arduino 并没有“获胜”，因为它绝不是出货量最大的微控制器，但在我看来，它几乎凭一己之力创造了微控制器在创客和业余爱好者运动中的庞大地位。
today yeah um i think a big part of it is they're pretty well connected with the maker community but they're also uh very accessible and you know not only are they making this board but they're also writing all these tutorials um you know they have a bunch of assets there's a whole class of you know oh here's a bluetooth chip uh that's designed for the arduino which means that there's a library which we'll get to later that you can link in to make use of this chip and so it's kind of like uh all of that extra work probably matters a lot more than you know do you have the best design yeah and i don't think anyone had attempted to think that was a market before that you know yeah there was basic stamps i don't know if you know about these
是的，我认为很大一部分原因是他们与创客社区联系非常紧密，而且也非常容易上手。你知道，他们不仅在制造这块板子，还在编写所有这些教程。你知道，他们有很多资源，有一整类东西，比如，“哦，这是一个为 Arduino 设计的蓝牙芯片”，这意味着有一个库（我们稍后会讲到），你可以将其链接起来以使用这个芯片。所以，所有这些额外的工作可能比“你是否有最好的设计”要重要得多。是的，而且我不认为在他们之前有人试图认为这是一个市场。你知道，是的，有 Basic Stamp，我不知道你是否知道这些。
basic stamps anyways um where you could write code in basic and use microcontrollers and i knew about these or whatever but they were always like quite expensive even compared to to these um and this never caught on because like you said there was never this uh enough of a network of tutorials and people using it and easy to use as a you know priority kind of thing they just never seemed to catch on um and then also one of the things that it was one of the very early things that is probably not the first by any means but it's one of the things i remember as being kind of an example of the open hardware and open software, where, you know, before people would say, well, here, I'll open the hardware, but I'll keep my, you know, drivers and firmware closed, or here's open source software, but I am not going to tell
总之，Basic Stamp，你可以用 Basic 语言编写代码并使用微控制器。我确实知道这些，但它们即使与这些相比也相当昂贵。而且这从未流行起来，因为正如你所说，从来没有足够的教程网络和使用它的人，也没有把“易用性”作为优先事项。它们似乎从未流行起来。而且，这也是非常早期的东西之一，虽然它绝不是第一个，但我记得它是开源硬件和开源软件的一个例子。在它之前，人们会说，“好吧，我会开放硬件，但我会保持驱动程序和固件封闭”，或者“这是开源软件，但我不会告诉你”
you the exact details of what I, you know, put on the chips and in the um you know in the board but the arduino stuff is open both the ide the software that goes on the sort of so-called firmware that goes on the the chips and the boards themselves are all completely open yeah yeah that's right um so yeah there's there's no reason why someone couldn't make you perfect replica of an Arduino and sell it themselves. And people do. We'll talk about that. Yeah. But I mean, I think the difference is that you just can't use the name.
我放在芯片和板子上的确切细节。但 Arduino 的东西是完全开放的，IDE、软件、所谓的固件，以及芯片和板子本身，都是完全开放的。是的，没错。所以，没有任何理由说明为什么有人不能制造一个完美的 Arduino 复制品并自己出售。人们确实这么做了。我们会谈到这一点。是的。但我的意思是，我认为区别在于你不能使用这个名字。
But yeah, so the Arduino really is this, as Jason was already sort of talking about, more than just the board. It's the board, the communities, the libraries. And we'll probably accidentally use the... When we use the term arduino for me i really mean all of those things together yeah um it isn't just any one of them um so the first thing to talk about is is sort of this arduino ide it's really not an amazing ide it's relatively simple in fact i think arduino project uh used it from i believe it's the processing project or something um where they already had this ide and they sort of reskinned it ported it um there's not really much to write home about but what's interesting there is that because the arduino is
但是的，正如 Jason 刚才所说，Arduino 不仅仅是那块板子。它是板子、社区和库的集合。当我们使用“Arduino”这个词时，我们可能会不经意地指所有这些东西的总和。是的，它不仅仅是其中任何一个。所以我们要谈的第一件事是 Arduino IDE。它真的不是一个令人惊叹的 IDE，它相对简单。事实上，我认为 Arduino 项目是从 Processing 项目或其他什么地方借用的，他们已经有了这个 IDE，然后他们重新设计了界面并移植了它。没什么值得大书特书的，但有趣的是，因为 Arduino
often the first embedded hardware and well unless you've done phone development is is common now i guess it's pretty similar where you do cross compiling where you have an ide and unlike visual studio or gcc where often you compile code and then run it on the computer that did the compiling you're compiling code on your computer and then sending it to a different kind of computer in this case the arduino which is we'll talk about in a minute, an AVR. And so you're doing this cross-compiling. So that's sort of one interesting nuance. And the second thing is that you then need to do the quote-unquote programming, not the write your program programming, but the putting your program on a board called programming. And so one of the things that the IDE is responsible for doing is making sure that you're doing the correct protocol for programming the boards you have plugged in and sending that
通常是人们接触的第一款嵌入式硬件。除非你做过手机开发，现在这很常见，我想这很相似，你进行交叉编译。你有一个 IDE，不像 Visual Studio 或 GCC，你通常在编译代码的计算机上运行代码，而你是先在你的计算机上编译代码，然后将其发送到另一种计算机，在这种情况下是 Arduino（我们稍后会谈到，它是 AVR）。所以你是在进行交叉编译。这是其中一个有趣的细微差别。第二件事是，你需要进行所谓的“编程”，不是编写程序的编程，而是将程序放入板子的过程，这被称为编程。所以 IDE 负责的一件事是确保你为插入的板子使用正确的协议进行编程，并发送该
code over. And then also doing the remote debugging where you can sort of, if your program goes awry, you can debug it from that IDE. But it does so over the USB connection to the board because the program isn't running locally your IDE is running locally but the actual code is running on the Arduino right, yeah exactly yeah, I've used the Arduino IDE for this robot arm I'm building
代码。然后还要进行远程调试，如果你的程序出错，你可以从那个 IDE 进行调试。但它是通过 USB 连接到板子进行的，因为程序不是在本地运行的，你的 IDE 在本地运行，但实际代码是在 Arduino 上运行的。对，没错。是的，我用 Arduino IDE 为我正在制作的机器人手臂编写过程序。
and yeah, I thought it was pretty reasonable the Arduino IDE for this robot arm I'm building. And yeah, I thought it was pretty reasonable. I mean, as Patrick said, it's nothing to write home about. But you know, it seemed you got the job done. It has some basic functionality. It'll tell you if you have errors, things like that. So one of the things that is interesting about the Arduino is that it is just really C and C++ that you use to do the programming in the Arduino IDE. I guess I should say that in actuality, you can run the same compiler that the Arduino IDE is running under the hood.
是的，我觉得 Arduino IDE 对于我正在制作的机器人手臂来说相当合理。正如 Patrick 所说，它没什么值得大书特书的。但你知道，它似乎完成了工作。它有一些基本功能。它会告诉你是否有错误，诸如此类。所以关于 Arduino 有趣的一点是，你在 Arduino IDE 中使用的确实是 C 和 C++。我想我应该说，实际上，你可以运行 Arduino IDE 在底层运行的同一个编译器。
And you can do everything yourself. And you could write in any language that has a back end that supports that um which i think there's probably llvm support for the avr back ends so you can probably write in almost any front-end language you want so you know probably c c++ java i don't know any any whatever llvm supports which is basically everything um but what is interesting about the cnc plus plus that the arduino it uses is this thing called wiring which is really just a set of they call it a core the core um it's a set of functions for doing things like turning a pin from a low voltage to a high voltage which could turn on an led for instance or reading a value off of a pin so that you could for instance tell what voltage is being
你可以自己做所有事情。你可以用任何有支持该后端语言的语言编写，我想 LLVM 可能支持 AVR 后端，所以你可能可以用几乎任何你想要的各种前端语言编写，比如 C、C++、Java，我不知道，任何 LLVM 支持的语言，基本上就是所有语言。但 Arduino 使用的 C/C++ 有趣之处在于这个叫做 Wiring 的东西，它实际上只是一组他们称之为“核心”的东西。它是一组用于执行诸如将引脚从低电压变为高电压（例如点亮 LED）或从引脚读取值（这样你就可以判断施加到该引脚的电压）之类的功能的函数，你可以通过可变电阻来控制它。这些确实只是函数调用，但你是在 Arduino IDE 提供的骨架应用程序中编写它们。在大多数情况下，你甚至不知道自己在写 C 语言。你没有做我们传统上与 C 语言或我与嵌入式编程相关联的事情，比如使用位掩码来设置寄存器值。这一切都隐藏在一组 C 函数调用中，你可以将其视为 Arduino API，或者这种 Wiring 语言，或者他们所说的“核心”。
applied to that pin which you could you know control from a variable resistor and those are really just function calls but you write them there see function, but you write them, they're C function calls, but you write them in the sort of skeleton app that the Arduino IDE provides you. And you really don't even know that you're writing C for the most part. You're not doing the things we traditionally associate with C or that I would associate with embedded programming, like using bit masking to set register values. That's all hidden away from you in a set of C function calls that you could think of as the Arduino API or as this wiring language or what they call kind of the core.
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并）
Yeah, so you're operating at this layer where you're just saying, hey, is the pin 7 high? Is their voltage coming across pin seven and uh and it just says yes or no so it's a boolean function but under the hood they're probably doing all sorts of wizardry like i guess they're checking the voltage that's above some threshold or something like that yeah i mean what they're doing is they're reading and writing what they call registers which are memory mapped uh ports that give you you use and access as if they were bits of ram but they're not they're um physical circuits
是的，所以你是在这个层面操作，你只是说，“嘿，7 号引脚是高电平吗？7 号引脚上有电压吗？”然后它只是回答是或否，所以这是一个布尔函数。但在底层，他们可能在做各种魔法，比如我猜他们在检查电压是否高于某个阈值之类的。是的，我的意思是，他们正在做的是读取和写入他们所谓的寄存器，这些是内存映射端口，你像使用 RAM 位一样使用和访问它们，但它们不是，它们是物理电路。
and uh but that's you're basically just scripting it but you're scripting it in c so this very accessible maker thing is really written in c which is somewhat uh not what you would expect, I guess, that that would be what caught on. Isn't there another language, though, like Scratch or something? Or am I just making that up? But I thought the Arduino came with like a language that they were pushing and the C was like an optional thing.
但你基本上只是在编写脚本，但你是在用 C 语言编写脚本。所以这个非常易于使用的创客工具实际上是用 C 语言编写的，这在某种程度上不是你所期望的，我想，这竟然会流行起来。难道没有其他语言吗，比如 Scratch 之类的？还是我编造的？但我以为 Arduino 自带了一种他们正在推广的语言，而 C 语言只是一个可选的东西。
I think, I mean, this wiring is this set of functions i don't know that it's any other language than just c oh okay so there is something called a sketch and a sketch that's what it is sketch a sketch just means a program though but different than if you sat down and wrote a program for your computer you would you know start it in c you would start with you know int main uh you know and then the i'm not gonna say it out loud because it gets hard but uh the the type signature necessary for main and then you would write your code in there um but one of the things that a sketch does is it really just says hey i need you to provide two functions for me the first is setup where you do your setup and then a function called loop which is i'm going to call it in a big loop for you and i want the
我想，我的意思是，这个 Wiring 是一组函数，我不知道它除了 C 语言之外还有什么其他语言。哦，好吧，所以有一个东西叫“草图”（sketch）。草图，就是那个东西。草图只是意味着一个程序。但与你坐在电脑前编写程序不同，你会用 C 语言开始，你会从 `int main` 开始，然后……我不会大声说出来，因为它很难……你需要 main 的类型签名，然后你在里面写代码。但草图所做的一件事是，它实际上只是说：“嘿，我需要你为我提供两个函数。”第一个是 `setup`，你在那里进行设置；然后是一个叫 `loop` 的函数，我会为你在一个大循环中调用它，你想要重复做的事情应该放在这个 `loop` 函数中。然后它所做的是，草图有一个外部文件，里面有那个 `main`，它调用底层平台，板子设置，在 `init` 函数中配置所有时钟速度等，然后它只是调用你的 `setup` 函数，然后在一个基本上是 `while(true)` 的循环中调用你的 `loop` 函数。
thing that you want to do repeatedly you should put in this loop function and then what it does is the sketch has an external file that has that main and it calls the underlying platform the board setup it configures all the clock speeds and everything in this init function then it just calls your setup function and then just calls your loop function in a uh basically a wild true loop um so there's a wild loop and it just calls your loop function uh and so a sketch is a file which you i think they have it dot ino and uh dot ino file or whatever but that's really just a c bit of c code that they embed into this other you know framework and they just call your setup function and call your loop function and you are just writing c in there but you often call these other functions that do all of the you
所以有一个 `while` 循环，它只是调用你的 `loop` 函数。所以草图是一个文件，我想他们把它叫做 `.ino` 文件，但那实际上只是你嵌入到这个框架中的一段 C 代码，他们只是调用你的 `setup` 函数和 `loop` 函数，你只是在里面写 C 代码，但你经常调用这些执行所有繁重硬件工作的其他函数。
know heavy hardware lifting for you yeah that makes sense uh it you know it when i when you kind of know what's going on it's surprisingly of simple, but it is rather clever to do it this way because it really makes all of the explanation you have to do to someone about why main has a bunch of parameters that come in and why is void main considered bad. Like, why are you supposed to have int main? Yeah, exit codes and all that. Yeah, like no one wants to explain that stuff. Like it's actually not really, I mean, it is important, but it isn't the most important thing to a beginner. Yeah, the other thing that's really cool is there's a list of example sketches,
是的，这很有道理。当你了解发生了什么时，它简单得令人惊讶，但以这种方式做确实很聪明，因为它确实省去了你必须向别人解释为什么 `main` 有一堆参数，为什么 `void main` 被认为是坏的。比如，为什么你应该有 `int main`？是的，退出代码之类的。是的，没人想解释那些东西。这实际上并不是，我的意思是，它很重要，但对初学者来说不是最重要的。是的，另一件很酷的事情是有一份示例草图列表，
and they're all one file because, you know, all the main and everything else has been done for you, and there's so many other libraries, et cetera, et cetera. So most of the time, you can do something simple in just one file. And so there are sketches that just one of them turns a stepper motor, like 360 degrees clockwise and 360 degrees anti-clockwise, and just keeps doing that in a loop. Another one has like a little joystick and you wire up a joystick to the correct pins,
它们都是单个文件，因为所有的 `main` 和其他一切都为你做好了，而且还有很多其他库等等。所以大多数时候，你可以在一个文件中做一些简单的事情。所以有些草图只是让步进电机顺时针转 360 度，逆时针转 360 度，并在循环中不断重复。另一个有一个小操纵杆，你把操纵杆连接到正确的引脚上，
you run this example sketch, and then it'll just tell you the x-axis of the joystick. It'll just print it to the screen. So if you move the joystick to the left, you start getting negative numbers, you move it to the right, you start getting positive numbers um and so these sketches these example sketches are just like right there in the ide you just go in a file example boom you get a list of like 30 examples um you know they all require some some hardware which we'll get to later there's packages that have all of the example hardware um but yeah just having that resource is super, super useful. Yeah, I mean, oftentimes, this has become now my thing with picking a Linux distribution is,
你运行这个示例草图，它就会告诉你操纵杆的 X 轴数值。它会直接打印到屏幕上。所以如果你把操纵杆向左移动，你开始得到负数；向右移动，你开始得到正数。所以这些草图，这些示例草图就在 IDE 里。你只需进入“文件”->“示例”，砰，你就会得到一个包含 30 个示例的列表。你知道，它们都需要一些硬件，我们稍后会讲到，有包含所有示例硬件的包。但拥有这些资源真的非常、非常有帮助。是的，我的意思是，这现在已经成为我选择 Linux 发行版的方式了，
I just want a Linux distribution that's most likely to have the answers to the question before I ask it. Yep. And that sounds really dumb, but I guess I've somewhat optimized my life around this for several things now, where if I know I'm getting into a hobbyist thing i just i kind of want to pick something that i know is going to have answers before i have a problem because otherwise i'm going to waste all my time
我只是想要一个最有可能在我提问之前就有答案的 Linux 发行版。是的。这听起来很蠢，但我猜我已经为几件事优化了我的生活，如果我知道我要进入一个业余爱好领域，我只想选择一个我知道在遇到问题之前就有答案的东西，否则我会浪费我所有的时间
trying to get them and arduino is really successful there as jason said like they've already given you examples on how to do a lot of things you're going to want to do read a resistor a variable resistor value a knob move a motor turn on an led you're not going to have to you know post a question on stack overflow to figure out how to do that right and some things have specifications like for example um there's an lcd panel where you can wire up i think it's like four or even eight pins it takes. I think it takes four pins. But, you know, with those four pins, there's an entire protocol that's saying, okay, you know, set these pins at these times. And, you know, with just those four pins,
去寻找它们。而 Arduino 在这方面非常成功，正如 Jason 所说，他们已经为你提供了如何做很多你想做的事情的示例：读取电阻、可变电阻值、旋钮、移动电机、点亮 LED。你不需要在 Stack Overflow 上发帖询问如何做到这一点，对吧？有些东西有规格说明，例如，有一个 LCD 面板，你可以连接，我想是四个甚至八个引脚。我想它需要四个引脚。但是，你知道，有了这四个引脚，有一整套协议说，“好的，在这些时间设置这些引脚。”而且，你知道，仅用那四个引脚，
you're going to display a whole bunch of stuff on this LED. Like you could fill the whole LED full of characters, right? LCD, sorry. And generally, that would be kind of a huge pain. It's some custom protocol. It's probably based on timing and all sorts of stuff. But Arduino just has a library for that protocol. So you import this Arduino library,
你就可以在这个 LED 上显示很多东西。就像你可以把整个 LED 填满字符，对吧？LCD，抱歉。通常，这会非常麻烦。这是一种自定义协议。它可能基于时序和各种各样的东西。但 Arduino 刚好有一个针对该协议的库。所以你导入这个 Arduino 库，
and then you just say, hey, I want the LCD to display JSON. And that's it. You don't have to think about the protocol it does all the work of of you know sending the right thing at the right time to just make the LCD display whatever you want and the thing that Arduino does one of the things Arduino does really good is instead of exposing you the 20 parameters that that protocol has, it just picks a reasonable default and doesn't bother you with the details.
然后你只需说，“嘿，我想要 LCD 显示 JSON。”就这样。你不需要考虑协议，它完成了所有工作，在正确的时间发送正确的东西，让 LCD 显示你想要的任何内容。Arduino 做得很好的一点是，它没有向你暴露该协议拥有的 20 个参数，而是选择了一个合理的默认值，不会用细节来烦你。
And you probably can get the details if you want them. But traditionally, you would have been exposed to a giant function setup where if there was already a library, which there probably wouldn't have been,
如果你想要，你可能可以得到这些细节。但传统上，你会被暴露在一个巨大的函数设置中，如果已经有一个库（可能还没有），
you would have had to go to the data sheet and figure it out yourself. And wouldn't have been, you would have had to go to the data sheet and figure it out yourself. And even if you did, you would have had to answer 20 questions you didn't know how to answer about timing, how fast you wanted to refresh and what amount of power do you want it to draw?
你将不得不去查阅数据手册并自己弄清楚。即使你这样做了，你也必须回答 20 个你不知道如何回答的关于时序的问题：你想刷新多快？你想让它消耗多少功率？
Yeah, exactly. I mean, I plugged in an LCD panel with Arduino and yeah, you know, put in a string and boom, it's rendered. So yeah, Arduino is, and maybe it's because, you know, Arduino knows the mega there's there's only a handful of different arduino chipsets or boards so um so they probably just handle these cases for you and they know what the right defaults are well yeah so so the we'll talk a little about the processor originally the first ones were targeting 8-bit atmel AVR chips, which are quite cheap chips. And the fact that they were 8-bit doesn't mean you could only do 8-bit math. It just means the processor is natively 8-bits. And so doing anything more than 8-bits takes multiple instructions. I won't get off into that right now. But they're surprisingly sort of low amount of resources and low amount of speed.
是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我用 Arduino 插入了一个 LCD 面板，然后输入一个字符串，砰，它就渲染出来了。所以是的，Arduino 是……也许是因为 Arduino 知道 Mega，只有少数几种不同的 Arduino 芯片组或板子，所以他们可能只是为你处理了这些情况，并且知道什么是正确的默认值。好吧，是的，所以我们要谈谈处理器。最初，第一批产品针对的是 8 位 Atmel AVR 芯片，这些芯片相当便宜。它们是 8 位的并不意味着你只能做 8 位数学运算。这只是意味着处理器原生是 8 位的。所以做任何超过 8 位的运算都需要多条指令。我现在就不展开讲了。但它们的资源和速度确实相当低。
But people still manage to do a lot with them because you're not doing things like rendering full graphics to a display. And so you can do, you know, kind of a lot with them more than you would think. But now there are, as Jason was saying, there's a whole bunch and they have moved on to other different kinds of processors. And the other thing to point out is that although the Arduino line itself is actually still, although much bigger than it was, still pretty small, there isn't anything from stopping you from implementing this core for other processors. So people have taken, you know, before Arduino had a Wi-Fi option, you know, took chips that had Wi-Fi on it and ported it. They've taken faster processors and ported the core to it so you can write Arduino sketches for other boards.
但人们仍然设法用它们做了很多事情，因为你不需要做诸如向显示器渲染完整图形之类的事情。所以你可以用它们做很多事情，比你想象的要多。但现在，正如 Jason 所说，有很多种，它们已经转向了其他不同类型的处理器。另外需要指出的是，虽然 Arduino 系列本身实际上仍然很小（尽管比以前大多了），但没有什么能阻止你为其他处理器实现这个核心。所以人们已经采取了行动，在 Arduino 有 Wi-Fi 选项之前，人们拿了带有 Wi-Fi 的芯片并移植了它。他们采用了更快的处理器并将核心移植到上面，这样你就可以为其他板子编写 Arduino 草图。
But one of the things that was pretty distinctive and other boards have adopted them as well that wasn't just this easy to use interface over the processor but they also did this certain board shape where they had these female headers facing up which are headers you could plug into and they exposed a lot of the almost all of the pins on these headers that face up so that you could you know a you could just poke a wire down into them to use which is when jason says he hooks up a screen you may just be as simple as literally like plugging a wire into that um that header uh and then they had what's called shields which like sit down on top of that in this form factor and plug right in and you know expose all the proper pins that you're going to have on this
但其中一个非常独特且其他板子也采用了的东西，不仅仅是处理器上易于使用的界面，他们还做了这种特定的板子形状，上面有朝上的母排针，你可以插入这些排针，并且他们将几乎所有的引脚都暴露在这些朝上的排针上，这样你就可以直接把电线插进去使用。当 Jason 说他连接屏幕时，可能就像直接把电线插进那个排针一样简单。然后他们有所谓的“扩展板”（Shields），它们以这种外形尺寸坐在上面，直接插进去，并暴露了你在这个扩展板上将拥有的所有正确引脚。
shield this extension board this add-on um is going to be exposed right to there and that was something they did that maybe other people had done that before but that was the first time i had seen something that that did that it was really quite clever yeah i'd never seen anything like it before the other thing too is you might say like all these ships are so underpowered etc etc let me just get a raspberry pi the raspberry pi is like 20 bucks right the thing about it is um you know the os is as patrick was saying the os is super super lightweight and on top of that the os is wait there is no os to be clear in the arduino uh well what is it called then i guess firmware i guess the i mean it's just the program yeah okay that's sure you could call it firmware that's fair
这个扩展板、这个附加组件，将直接暴露在那里。这是他们做的事情，也许以前别人也做过，但这是我第一次看到这样做，这真的很聪明。是的，我以前从未见过类似的东西。另一件事是，你可能会说，“所有这些芯片动力不足等等，让我买个树莓派吧。”树莓派只要 20 美元，对吧？关于它的问题是，你知道，操作系统，正如 Patrick 所说，操作系统非常非常轻量级，而且最重要的是，操作系统是……等等，明确一下，Arduino 没有操作系统。好吧，那它叫什么？我猜是固件。我的意思是，它只是程序。是的，好吧，你可以称之为固件，这很公平。
yeah yeah yeah so uh you know raspberry pi uh let's say you miswire something and you want to you know shut down the raspberry pi plug in some different discrets and turn it back on like it has a boot up sequence you could corrupt the file system right unless d card right it's not really designed for you to be constantly plugging and unplugging things um you know it's gonna take a long time to boot up, etc. The Arduino just starts within, I don't know, two seconds or something. There's no disk, no file system
是的，是的。所以，你知道，树莓派，假设你接线错误，你想关闭树莓派，插入一些不同的离散元件，然后重新打开。它有一个启动序列，你可能会损坏文件系统，对吧？SD 卡，对吧？它并不是真的设计成让你不断地插拔东西。你知道，它启动需要很长时间，等等。Arduino 只需要两秒钟左右就能启动。没有磁盘，没有文件系统
that you're going to corrupt or anything like that. And it has... The ResRate Pi has a lot of the same pins, but for development, it's going to be a very painful experience to develop on the pi yeah as jason pointed out i mean the raspberry pi processor is way more powerful than what's on the arduino but they're not really meant to do the same thing right yeah so you're not you're not meant to be rendering windows in a full linux distro
你会损坏它或类似的东西。而且它有……树莓派有很多相同的引脚，但对于开发来说，在树莓派上开发将是一次非常痛苦的经历。是的，正如 Jason 指出的，我的意思是，树莓派处理器比 Arduino 上的强大得多，但它们并不是真的为了做同样的事情，对吧？是的，所以你不是为了在完整的 Linux 发行版中渲染窗口。
uh if you they actually do have an arduino now be rendering windows in a full linux distro uh if you they actually do have an arduino now that i think has a full linux distribution on it um which is sort of confusing but for the most part weird that's for the most part that's not what people use the arduinos for it's more like jason said just you would have it to toggle some pins turn on some leds move some motors um and doing that from Linux is, to me, actually slightly awkward. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, and if you wanted, if you needed the horsepower to run, like, a camera or something like that,
如果你……他们现在确实有一个 Arduino，我想上面有一个完整的 Linux 发行版，这有点令人困惑。但大多数情况下，人们使用 Arduino 并不是为了那个。更像是 Jason 说的，你只是用它来切换一些引脚、点亮一些 LED、移动一些电机。而从 Linux 做这些事情，对我来说，实际上有点尴尬。是的。我的意思是，如果你需要马力来运行像摄像头之类的东西，
you could always take something that works on the Arduino and, you know, as long as you're using the same pins on the Raspberry Pi or do some mapping or something like that. But you don't want to be doing the development on a Pi. That'd be bad. Yep, and so one of the things about all the different hardware, as Jason already mentioned, is that they have these really awesome libraries
你总是可以拿一些在 Arduino 上能用的东西，只要你在树莓派上使用相同的引脚或进行一些映射之类的。但你不想在树莓派上进行开发。那会很糟糕。是的，所以关于所有不同硬件的一件事，正如 Jason 已经提到的，是它们有这些非常棒的库，
that you can download and use. So there's a bunch of included ones for things like moving stepper motors, but then there's all sorts of other ones for things like moving stepper motors but then there's all sorts of other ones for like i want to know the barometric pressure outside i want to know the temperature from this chip i want to record sounds i you know all sorts of little chips that go into cell phones and cars and airplanes and you name it uh you know accelerometers whatever these kind of devices get made in the by the millions and airplanes and you name it uh you know accelerometers whatever these kind of devices get
你可以下载并使用。所以有很多内置的库用于移动步进电机之类的东西，但还有各种各样的其他库，比如我想知道外面的气压，我想知道这个芯片的温度，我想录制声音，你知道，所有进入手机、汽车、飞机的小芯片，随你怎么说，你知道，加速度计，无论什么。这些设备被成千上万地制造出来，
made in the by the millions and millions and people mount them on you know adapter boards little pcb boards to work with arduino and then provide these libraries so that they're just become really quite easy to use yeah i mean one thing that kind of shocked me when i first got started with arduino a few months back is uh the fact that yeah i mean if you need drivers for everything right i mean like like even if you get let's say hypothetically you get a usb adapter like a usb i think usb is just four pins right so you could you know take a usb device and you could plug it into four pins, right? So you could, you know, take a USB device and you could plug it into four pins in your Arduino. But at the end of the day, like you need a driver, like with Linux or with Windows, you plug in a USB joystick and there's like a generic, you know, hid driver that covers almost
人们把它们安装在适配器板上，即小 PCB 板，以便与 Arduino 一起工作，然后提供这些库，使它们变得非常容易使用。是的，我的意思是，几个月前我刚开始接触 Arduino 时，有一件事让我感到震惊，那就是，是的，如果你需要一切的驱动程序，对吧？我的意思是，即使你假设你得到了一个 USB 适配器，比如 USB，我想 USB 只有四个引脚，对吧？所以你可以拿一个 USB 设备，把它插到四个引脚上。但在一天结束时，你需要一个驱动程序，就像 Linux 或 Windows 一样，你插入一个 USB 操纵杆，有一个通用的 HID 驱动程序覆盖了几乎
any joystick, right? With Arduino, I mean, that might exist also for Arduino. I haven't actually looked about joysticks. But it's a completely different universe. And so things which are very simple when you have, I guess, to use Patrick's words, when you have an operating system, you become very hard in Arduino as well. But that is the way it works. So this is actually great education. And there is a lot of job opportunity for this, which is things like, you know, the exact protocol that's running over USB that allows your joystick to work or that your phone processor uses to talk
任何操纵杆，对吧？对于 Arduino，我的意思是，这可能也存在于 Arduino 中。我实际上没有研究过操纵杆。但这是一个完全不同的宇宙。所以，当你拥有操作系统时非常简单的事情，用 Patrick 的话说，在 Arduino 中也会变得非常困难。但这就是它的工作方式。所以这实际上是很好的教育，而且这有很多工作机会，比如，在 USB 上运行的允许你的操纵杆工作的确切协议，或者你的手机处理器用来与摄像头通信以控制它的协议。但如果你在 Arduino 上，你就会考虑这些事情。有很多库可以帮助你。但你将了解这些东西是如何工作的以及这意味着什么。运行这些协议更快或更慢，或者在长距离上运行的权衡是什么，以及当不同设备需要不同电压才能工作时会发生什么？是的，我还没弄明白那个。所以我们谈了一些关于外部硬件的内容，但 Arduino 也有一些内部硬件。它有一些电压调节器，所以可以在其输出引脚上提供不同的电压。它确实有一些模数转换器，这允许你读取外部电压。所以如果你连接了一个麦克风、一个光传感器，或者像我们谈到的，一个电位器，一个
to the camera to control it. But if you're on Arduino, you're going to be thinking about those things. And there are a lot of libraries to help you out. But you're going to learn about how those things work and what it means. What are the tradeoffs for running those protocols faster or slower or over long distances and about what happens when different devices require different voltages to work at? Yeah, I still haven't figured that one out. So we talked a little bit about external hardware but the arduino also has some internal hardware so it has some voltage regulators so providing different voltages on its output pins it does have um some analog to digital converters which are what allow you to read external voltages so if you hooked up a microphone or a light sensor or um you know like we were talking about uh you know a potentiometer a
可变电阻，你用它作为旋钮来控制某物的位置，这些最终都会产生所谓的模拟电压。它只是一个在两个设定值之间平滑移动的电压，所以它可能是 0 到 5 伏，它可以是中间的任何值。但当然，Arduino 不能表示 0 到 5 之间无限数量的值，所以它必须把它们变成离散的步骤。这被称为采样，它对它们进行采样并使它们成为离散集。所以如果你说 0 到 5，我将使用 8 位。所以我有 256 个值来表示 0 到 5 之间。所以你把 0 到 5 的范围切成 256 个桶。
variable resistor um that you were using to use as like a knob to control you know the position of something um those all ultimately produce a what's called an analog voltage it's just a voltage that moves smoothly between a two set value so it might go zero to five volts and it could be just any value in between but of course the arduino can't represent the infinite number of values between zero and five so it has to make them into discrete steps and it's called sampling it samples them and makes them into the discrete set. So if you say zero to five, and I'm going to use eight bits. So I have 256 values to represent between zero and five. And so you cut up the range zero to five into 256 buckets.
然后你看看电压当前落在哪个桶里。这就是模数转换器的作用。Arduino 内部有一些这样的转换器，这样你就可以在库中使用它们，使它变得非常容易，你只需说，我想它只是 `analogRead`，它就会给你一个 0 到 255 的答案，告诉你电压当前在哪个桶里。是的，是的。然后你可以做模拟输出，我相信基础 Arduino 实际上没有数模转换器，那会给你这个。所以相反，他们做的是所谓的脉冲宽度调制（PWM），我不会深入探讨，它实际上非常复杂，但基本上它产生一个方波，
And then you see which bucket the voltage currently falls in. That's what an analog to digital converter does. And the Arduino has some of these internally so that you can use them in libraries for making it really easy where you just say i think it's just analog read and it just gives you a 0 to 255 answer for which bucket the voltage is currently in yep yep um then you can do uh it can do analog out which i believe the base arduinos don't actually have digital to analog converters which would give you this so instead they do what's called pulse width modulation which i won't get into it's actually really complicated but basically it makes a square wave
在周期内开启一定的百分比，然后用电容器平滑它，这样你就会得到一个大致对应那个电压的电压。所以你可以做模拟输出，对吧？或者如果你想移动一个伺服电机，它直接使用 PWM，那就是你实际将其移动到某个角度的方法。没错。所以我有一个机器人手臂，只是用
that is on for a certain percentage of the cycle and then smooths that out with a capacitor so that you get a voltage that's roughly, you know, corresponding that. So you could do analog, right? Or if you wanna move a servo motor, which uses PWM directly, that would be how you actually move it to a certain angle. That's right. So I have, you know, the robot arm is just done
一堆伺服电机完成的。正如 Patrick 所说，如果你给出四分之三的电压，它就会移动四分之三的距离。你知道，如果 0 是最左边，你给出总电压的四分之三，它就会从左到右移动四分之三。你可以控制它。而 Arduino 将这一切抽象化，你实际上只需要给出度数。哦，真的吗？角度？不错。是的，是的，完全正确。你只需说，“我想要它转到 45 度”，它就会为你算出一切。
with a bunch of servos. And if you, as Patrick said, if you give, let's say, three-fourths of the voltage, then it's going to move three-fourths of the way. You know, if zero is, you know, all the way to the left and you give it three-fourths of the total voltage, it'll move, you know, three-fourths of the way from left to right. And you can control it. And Arduino abstracts all of this away to where you literally just give it the degree. Oh, really? The angle? Nice. Yeah, yeah, exactly. You just say, like, I want it to go to angle, you know, 45 degrees, and it just figures it all out for you.
那真的很好。是的。然后我们谈了一些关于扩展板的内容。所以，我的意思是，你有……你用过任何扩展板吗，Jason？我没有。有一个伺服扩展板。所以，不是要深入探讨这个细节，但有步进电机和伺服电机。基本上，伺服电机最多只能转，我想是 270 度。
That's really nice. Yeah. And then we talked a little bit about shields. So, I mean, do you have some – have you used any shields, Jason? I haven't. There is a servo shield. So there's, not to get into too much detail about this, but there's stepper motors and servos. Basically, servos can only go, I think at most, 270 degrees.
所以它们不能像那样绕圈旋转。但伺服电机是有自我意识的，所以你可以告诉伺服电机，“转到 23 度”，它就会去那里，对吧？它是闭环的。闭环，是的。当它启动时，它知道它处于什么角度等等。嗯，这不仅仅是闭环，对吧？因为步进电机，我相信也是闭环的。不。不？好吧，步进电机，你给它一个差值。
So they can't, you know, spin around in a circle or anything like that. But the servos are self-aware so you could tell a servo you know go to degree 23 and it'll just go there right it's a closed loop closed loop yeah and when it starts it knows what degree it's at and everything um well it's more than just closed loop right right? Because a stepper motor, I believe, is also closed loop. No. No? Well, the stepper motor, you give it a difference.
你说，“我想要它走两步”，然后它会确保它走了那两步。哦，这变得非常迂腐了。这不重要。实际上，步进电机，如果你拿着电机，或者它过载了，你告诉它移动，但它不能移动，它实际上不会知道它成功还是失败。哦，这就是为什么如果你的 3D 打印机撞到打印件并跳步，导致它错位，这就是发生的事情。它丢失了步数，它撞到了什么东西，无法移动，但它不知道
You say, like, I want it to take two steps, and then it will make sure that it takes those two steps. Oh, this is getting really off into pedantic stuff. It's not important. Actually, the stepper motor, if you're holding like the motor or it's like over torqued and you tell it to move and it can't it won't actually know if it succeeded or failed oh which is why if you're if you ever have your 3d printer hit the print and skip where it like misaligns that's what happens it it lost steps it hit something and couldn't move but it didn't know
它无法移动。伺服电机是闭环的，它会继续与你对抗，如果你抓住它，它会一直对抗，直到它到达你告诉它的位置。有趣，好吧。但总之，步进电机需要……我不知道为什么步进电机需要这么多引脚。可能只是不同的技术。步进电机需要两个引脚，而伺服电机只需要一个。所以你可以买一个扩展板，它给你更多的引脚。这样你就可以控制八个步进电机之类的。但是的，我没有必要这样做，因为我主要只使用伺服电机。是的，所以，但有用于……的扩展板。
it couldn't move the servo the servo is closed up it will continue to fight you and if you hold it it will just keep fighting and until it gets to the position you told it to interesting okay so but anyways the stepper motor takes i don't know why the stepper motor takes so many more pins. It's probably just whatever the different technology is. The stepper motor takes two pins, and the servo only takes one. And so there's a shield you can buy, which gives you just a lot more pins. So you can control eight stepper motors or something like that. But yeah, I haven't had a need to do that since i'm only using servos mostly uh yeah so but there's shields for
它无法移动伺服电机，因为伺服电机是闭环的，它会继续与你对抗。如果你按住它，它会一直对抗，直到到达你指定的指令位置。很有趣，好吧。但无论如何，步进电机需要……我不知道为什么步进电机需要更多的引脚，可能只是因为技术不同吧。步进电机需要两个引脚，而伺服电机只需要一个。所以你可以买一个扩展板，它能提供更多的引脚，这样你就可以控制八个步进电机之类的设备。但目前我还没有这种需求，因为我主要还是使用伺服电机，不过确实有这样的扩展板。
everything so you can imagine so a printed circuit board a pcb is like a piece of fiberglass with metal traces and the circuitry sitting on it and that's what the arduino board itself is but then you can basically get another board that plugs into the arduino board that is shaped often similar to the arduino board and you could have a display on it you could have like jason was saying a whole bunch of connections for servos and stuff uh you could have it like be able to control lots and lots of leds there's all sorts of crazy ones there's ones with batteries on them so you can actually run the arduino without it being plugged in oh cool yeah so you can find all sorts of uh shields and these shields are just like a common shape and a set of libraries is normally what's expected that allow you to plug in to the arduino and add functionality add hardware that it didn't start out with
你可以想象一下，印刷电路板（PCB）就像是一块带有金属线路和电路的玻璃纤维板，Arduino板本身就是这样。但你基本上可以买到另一块插在Arduino板上的板子，它的形状通常与Arduino板相似，上面可以有显示屏，就像Jason说的，可以有各种连接伺服电机之类的接口，还可以控制大量的LED灯。各种各样的扩展板都有，有的甚至自带电池，这样你就不需要插电也能运行Arduino。太酷了，是的，你可以找到各种各样的扩展板，这些扩展板通常形状统一，并且配有一套预期的库，让你能够插入Arduino并添加它原本不具备的功能和硬件。
yeah that makes sense. So I think we've talked about, we've mentioned GPIO. We haven't said what it is. GPIO just means general purpose input output. And so what that means is the, you know, you can plug something like a servo into one of these pins and send signals out to that servo, you could also plug in something like a joystick that's sending data into the Arduino, and the same pin can do either or. Yeah, so sometimes a pin could be an input, and sometimes a pin could be an output,
是的，这很有道理。我想我们已经提到了GPIO，但还没解释它是什么。GPIO就是通用输入输出接口。它的意思是，你可以把像伺服电机这样的东西插到这些引脚上，向伺服电机发送信号；你也可以插上像操纵杆这样的东西，向Arduino发送数据，同一个引脚既可以做输入也可以做输出。
and it can switch back and forth it's it's programmable right um so yeah so as far as things you plug into the arduino so um yeah there's i mean a ton of stuff there's there's as you said motors lcd panels um you know there's things that sense water so you can have a little thing which is like, it looks kind of like a long circuit board. But what it's actually doing is it's telling you the water level. So it's just, I guess, I'm not quite sure from a physics standpoint how it works. But you would stick this and it will just tell you how much
而且它可以来回切换，它是可编程的。所以，关于你可以插到Arduino上的东西，真的非常多。正如你所说，有电机、LCD面板，还有能感应水的传感器。它看起来像是一块长条形的电路板，但实际上它是在告诉你水位。我不太确定从物理角度它是怎么工作的，但你把它插进去，它就会告诉你
of this board is full with water, so where the water line is. There's all sorts of crazy stuff, cameras, there's depth sensors, things like that. But ultimately, everyone wants to make a robot, is that right? I feel that's the... Yeah, I mean, everyone at some point know some type of motor or some set of motors and then some type of input um you know there's like a camera or or some kind of like a stop sensor or something like that and all of that is totally doable with arduino and the libraries make
这块板子有多少浸在水里，也就是水位线在哪里。还有各种各样的东西，比如摄像头、深度传感器等等。但归根结底，每个人都想做一个机器人，对吧？我觉得这就是……是的，每个人在某个时候都会用到某种电机或一组电机，然后加上某种输入，比如摄像头或某种停止传感器之类的。所有这些用Arduino都能完全实现，而且库让这一切
it make it super super easy to use so there's like a depth sensor um that's compatible with arduino which which typically when they say compatible with Arduino, what they mean is that they're providing some type of software. The Arduino IDE also has a sort of repository of libraries. So if someone makes a depth sensor, they can upload the depth sensor, uh you know library to to the arduino you know cloud i guess and um so you'd put the part number and you'd get their library and uh yeah the libraries are really where the magic is because like i've been getting kind of more into it i really thought that i was gonna have to learn a lot more than i actually did
变得超级简单。比如有一个深度传感器与Arduino兼容，通常当他们说与Arduino兼容时，意思是他们提供某种软件。Arduino IDE也有一个库存储库。所以如果有人制作了一个深度传感器，他们可以把深度传感器的库上传到Arduino云端。你只需要输入零件编号，就能得到他们的库。库真的是魔法所在，因为我越深入了解，就越发现我其实不需要学那么多东西，
and it's because the libraries are just hiding all of the complexity from me. Yeah, I mean, I think Arduino is really awesome. It isn't something where you would ever get a job using an Arduino. I mean, maybe there are, but it would be an exception. Yeah, highly unlikely. Very unlikely. But it does introduce you into a world it's a bridge because to go from not knowing how to program to doing embedded programming is a really big jump there's
因为库帮我隐藏了所有的复杂性。是的，我认为Arduino真的很棒。虽然你不太可能靠使用Arduino找到工作，也许有，但那是个例外。是的，极不可能。非常不可能。但它确实把你引入了一个世界，它是一座桥梁，因为从不懂编程到进行嵌入式编程是一个很大的跨越，有
a lot of things you have to pick up and so what the arduino has really done um or has at least brought into the mainstream is the ability to use a little bit of programming and a little bit of understanding of electronics and still do really cool things. Yeah, exactly. And so there's, there's a lot of kits and starter packages. Um, I'll say the one I got, um, I think I, my heuristic was basically a lot of Amazon reviews. So I didn't do a ton of research, but they're also not very expensive, which is really nice. So I got the Elegoo Ultimate Arduino Kit from Amazon. But basically, it came with a... Elegoo is a company that manufactures electro components. And so they made made following the spec
很多东西需要学习。Arduino真正做到的是，或者说至少带入主流的是，让你能够利用一点编程知识和一点电子学理解，就能做出非常酷的东西。是的，没错。有很多套件和入门包。我买的那套，我的启发式方法基本上是看亚马逊评论。我没有做大量的研究，但它们也不贵，这很好。我从亚马逊买了Elegoo Ultimate Arduino套件。基本上，它带有一个……Elegoo是一家制造电子元件的公司，他们按照开源硬件规范制造了自己的Arduino。
that open source hardware specification they made their own Arduino and so you get this kit it's I would say it's maybe like 16 or 18 inches by about 12 inches but it's about
所以你买了这个套件，我想它大约是16或18英寸长，12英寸宽，但大约有
2 or 3 inches high so it's relatively thin this box comes with a bunch of like this, but it's about two or three inches high. So it's relatively thin. This box comes with like a bunch of resistors, voltage regulators, all sorts of sensors, motors, servos, stepper motors, all this stuff, the Arduino. And then you can go on their website or you can using the CD that's included. I literally didn't have a CD reader but I got everything off their website you know PDF manual and it's a really long manual you don't have to go through all of it but it's just a ton of different things you can do with Arduino so for example you know I want to build this robot arm so I went straight to the servo section.
2到3英寸高，所以它相对较薄。这个盒子里装了一堆电阻、稳压器、各种传感器、电机、伺服电机、步进电机，所有这些东西，还有Arduino。你可以去他们的网站，或者使用附带的CD。我真的没有CD驱动器，但我从他们的网站上下载了所有东西，比如PDF手册。手册很长，你不需要全部看完，但里面有各种各样你可以用Arduino做的事情。例如，我想做一个机械臂，所以我直接跳到了伺服电机部分。
And the cool thing, it has pictures. So it has a sort of schematic of what it should look like once you've plugged in the servo and everything. And then it has like actual real-life pictures of what it should look like. So if you have trouble reading the schematic, you can see the picture and say, oh, like I'm doing this wrong or what have you. The other thing, I've yet to you know blow anything up actually i did blow up a stepper motor controller um that was completely my fault um um it's kind of a long story i basically touched it on this like box this metal box and it shorted out um so yeah just quick psa don't have like a lot of metal things around um when you're when you have just like bare pc and when you say blow up i assume you mean
最酷的是，它有图片。它有一种示意图，显示插上伺服电机后应该是什么样子。然后它还有实际的实物照片，显示它应该是什么样子。所以如果你看不懂示意图，你可以看图片，然后说，哦，我做错了或者其他什么。另外，我还没把什么东西弄炸，其实我确实弄炸了一个步进电机控制器，那完全是我的错。这是一个很长的故事，我基本上把它碰到了这个金属盒子上，然后短路了。所以，快速提醒一下，当你只有裸露的PCB时，不要在周围放太多金属物品。当你提到弄炸时，我假设你的意思是
you let the magic smoke inside the chip that makes it work come out yeah actually like caused explosion oh no no it was just a tiny pop, and some smoke came out. And that stepper motor controller was only like 80 cents, so it wasn't a big loss. But yeah, yeah, nothing, like I was in no danger or anything. But yeah, so I went through this kit, and it was fascinating. I mean, I learned so much by going through the kit. They also explain things like how to read a resistor. So the resistor has certain colored bands,
你让芯片内部工作的魔法烟雾跑出来了。是的，实际上并没有引起爆炸，哦不，只是发出了一声轻微的爆裂声，冒出了一些烟。那个步进电机控制器才8毛钱，所以损失不大。但确实，我没有任何危险。总之，我研究了这个套件，非常着迷。我通过这个套件学到了很多。他们还解释了如何读取电阻，电阻上有特定的色环，
and there's a certain procedure where you can look at those bands and then know the level of resistance. So it talks about a lot of – it covers – it touches a lot of different areas. And you end up with, like, real, like, tangible things that you could take pictures of show your friends stuff like that so so check it out all right that's well pretty much we must have had a lot of uh pent-up discussion because this has become a very long episode yeah yeah there's a lot going on it's been a
有一种特定的程序，你可以查看这些色环，然后知道电阻值。它涵盖了很多不同的领域。最终你会得到一些真实的、有形的、可以拍照展示给朋友看的东西。所以去看看吧。好了，这基本上就是……我们一定积压了很多讨论，因为这已经变成了一期很长的节目。是的，确实发生了很多事情，已经
it's been a long time but uh thanks again for everyone for your support we're definitely going to get the um you know christmas gifts out asap so probably in the next you know few weeks or month or so yep um and uh yeah definitely if you've built anything with arduino send us some pictures we'll post it on facebook and uh we've gotten a lot more Facebook followers. We're up to something like 6,000. So thank you for that. And, yeah, we'll post to all 6,000 people a picture of your Arduino experiment and send it to us.
过了很长时间了。再次感谢大家的支持，我们肯定会尽快寄出圣诞礼物，可能在接下来的几周或一个月左右。是的，如果你用Arduino做了什么东西，一定要发照片给我们，我们会发布在Facebook上。我们的Facebook粉丝多了很多，已经达到6000左右了。所以谢谢你们。是的，我们会向所有6000人展示你的Arduino实验照片，发给我们吧。
So, yeah. And then everyone will star your GitHub repository. That's right. That's right. That's right. And then you can get the raise you've always wanted based on your GitHub repository. All right. Until next time. See you later.
好的。然后每个人都会给你的GitHub仓库加星。没错，没错。然后你就可以根据你的GitHub仓库得到你一直想要的加薪了。好了，下次见。再见。
The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明Patrick和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。